Ihr hört CRE: Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und die 198zigste Ausgabe
vom CRE wartet auf euch und Heute geht's um was ganz schlüpfriges, diesmal muss einfach mal
son super Thema daher denn die Gelegenheit darüber zu sprechen hat sich ergeben und ja es geht kurz gesagt
um Porno Pornographie und alles was damit verbunden ist. Und da reden wir dann mit Tina. Hallo Tina.
Hallo Tim.
Tina, Tina Lorenz du bist ja mit dem Thema ein wenig vertraut.
Ein bisschen.
Warum eigentlich?
Gute Frage das begleitet mich, das Thema begleitet mich seit ich würde sagen mehr als 10 Jahren.
Ich hab damals nach der Schule angefangen zu Jobben in einer ganz kleinen Web Bude, die hat Webseiten
gemacht unzwar nicht irgendwelche Webseiten sondern Pornowebseiten.
Aha
Der Chef dieser Bude war ein ehemaliger Werbechef von Procter and Gamble der hat da irgendwie Pampers
-Marketing gemacht und dann hatte er sich gedacht "Naja in die Windeln scheißen das kommt immer, also das ist irgendwie
ein ein Bereich mit Zukunft aber Pornographie ist noch viel besser" so.
Und dann hat er sich selbstständig gemacht mit Pornos und hat sich dann sone Web Bude aufgebaut und ich
hab für den Webseiten gemacht das war so meine erste Berührung mit dem Thema.
Wie bist denn da überhaupt rein geraten?
Durch Zufall ich wollte was mit Computern machen nach der Schule und dann kam es dazu.
Kam es einfach dazu.
Jor kam es dazu und da hab ich halt festgestellt wie das so funktioniert und das sehr sehr viel
im pornographischen Bereich einfach auch Fake ist oder sich ausgedacht also ich hab mir unter anderem.
Ich habe Bilder gekauft vom Bilderwebseiten, habe mir Geschichten ausgedacht und Charaktere ausgedacht
und habe dann Fanbriefe bekommen auf diese Fakecharaktere und so. Also das war son bisschen...
Sag mal was was ich meine was was war der Inhalt dieser Webseiten?
Das war so Amateurpornographie, so hallo guck mich an ich bin Cindy ich bin jetzt hier...
Meinst du jetzt Foto oder Video?
Ja ja Foto
Einfach nur Fotos?
Hey das war irgendwie in den späten 90er also da war gerade, das war gerade so diese große Zeit
der Dialer und so weiste?
hehe
Also das das ist alles noch das ist schon sehr lange her und damit konnte man echt Geld verdienen.
so mit affiliate links und so.
Ok also so quasi kostenlosen Inhalt ins Web einfach irgendwie
hm
Mädchenfotos mit Aussage oder was?
Genau und dann Links setzen auf affiliate Sachen und damit konnte man echt Büromiete zahlen.
Kauf dir, kauf dir was für... auf was wurde denn da verwiesen?
Naja auf halt kommerzielle Pornoseiten also...
Ach so verstehe ich will jetzt Links so zu sagen in Pornoumfeld.
Genau, jedenfalls das war meine erste meine erste Berührung so überhaupt mit dem Thema und das hat mich...
Was hast du dir dabei gedacht? Also ich meine was hast du
WAS HAST DU DIR DABEI GEDACHT?
um Gottes Willen was hat deine Mutter dazu gesagt
Ja
Nee ich meine was was dachtest du so als das dir klar wurde das das so jetzt dein Feld sein wird?
Das war mir in dem Moment nicht so klar also das mich das jetzt halt solange begleiten würde
war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht so absehbar aber es war halt immer interessant und es war immer ne gute Party-Anekdote.
Und dann hab ich irgendwann halt angefangen mich auch wissenschaftlich damit auseinander zu setzen.
Ja ok verstehe.. wissenschaftlich?
Ja so ganz, also richtig das ist kein Euphemismus sondern tatsächlich wissenschaftlich ich habe dann
meine Magisterarbeit über das Thema geschrieben.
Magisterarbeit in welchem Bereich?
In der leider in der Amerikanische Literaturgeschichte ich sage leider weil ich eigentlich Theaterwissenschaftlerin bin.
Ich habe in München studiert und die Münchner Theaterwissenschaftler haben gesagt "Um Gottes Willem das P-Wort
das darfst du nicht erwähnen du darfst über Körperarbeit in der in der Performancekunst reden aber nicht über das P-Wort
und um Gottes Willen keine Bilder, die Professoren müssen das noch lesen.
Also das ging dann nicht. Weil diese Art von Selbstzensur fand ich nicht schön deswegen bin ich zu den
Amerikanisten gegangen das war damals mein Nebenfach und die haben halt gesagt ja das ist uns total egal
komm halt das das kriegen schon hin und dann konnte ich da meine Magisterarbeit schreiben und der Prof. dann hat gesagt
Was war denn dann der Titel dieser Arbeit?
Der Titel war tatsächlich "The Body in Pornography - Corporeality as a Site of Loss"
Es ging um Pornographische Körper, erotische Köper,
es ging um Körperselbst die Verbindung zwischen dem Zuschauer und dem dem dem
Darsteller und der Darstellerin in Pornofilmen und ich hab mich in der Magisterarbeit auch ganz viel mit
viktorianische Pornographie beschäftig also mit schriftlicher Pornographie. Ich war dann forschen im größtem
Pornoinstitut der Welt im Kinsey Institute in Bloomington, Indiana fünf Wochen lang Bücher mit mysteriösen
Flecken an den spannenden Stellen durch blättern das war fantastisch.
Mysteriösen Flecken?
Naja klar
Achso du meinst so...
wenn's dann so so richtig zur Sache ging dann waren die Seiten verklebt und so ja ja so.
USA halt
Ja ja ne ne 100 bis 200 Jahre alte Spermaflecken und so das
Ach die
Überklebung verstehe alles klar
ja ja das war fantastisch
Wie wie groß war dieses Archiv also?
Das ist, das ist sehr groß also ich es gibt eigentlich also was was sie haben die Klassiker und so.
Sie haben sie bemühen sich ja seit den 1950ern seit Alfred Kinsey tatsächlich dieses Institut gegründet hat
bemühen sie sich um eine möglichst eine Vollständige Abbildung der der Literatur und und filmischen Artefakte.
Sie haben eine sehr sehr große Stummfilmsammlung, ne sehr große Sammlung von Werken aus der Libertinage
und und Victorianischen Pornographie. Und sie sind tatsächlich immer noch gefördert also das ist das in Amerika
das einzige Institut das halt diese Sammlung auch aus Staatsgeldern tatsächlich anhäufen darf.
Weil ansonsten ist ja die Prüderie ganz gut verbreitet oder?
Geht so also es das ist halt son bisschen dieser die berufen sich halt auf Freiheit der Wissenschaft und das ist
auch an der Uni angegliedert ja naja was heißt Prüderie also Pornographie ist halt immer ein Teil unserer Kultur
schon immer gewesen der son bisschen unter fernerliefen und unterm Radar lief ne.
Tja. Ok. Das bringt uns im Prinzip ja also mich zumindest auf die Frage was wie lange also.
Ich meine seit wann gibt’s denn das?
Pornographie?
Ja. ist das wieder so wie immer also gab's schon immer
Ja
oder?
Also ich glaube es gibt es gibt Darstellungen von also erotische Darstellungen gibt es solange Menschen existieren.
Also die Venus von Willendorf ist da zum Beispiel so ein ein Beispiel aus der Steinzeit oder Bronzezeit.
Aber das Wort Pornographie hat seinen Ursprung im griechischen als Pornographos und Pronographos ist
tatsächlich das schreibe über Prostituierte. Also die Prostitution selbst hat nen anderen anderen Wortursprung
aber das schreiben über Prostituierte das war damals im antiken Griechenland mit Pornographos gemeint
und das bedeutete also das beinhaltete alle schriftlichen Werke über die Ausübung des Berufes
über die Prostituierten selber und auch Darstellungen von Prostitution.
ehem
Nicht so unbedingt das was wir jetzt unter Pornographie verstehen würden aber die antiken Griechen hatten auch son
bisschen anderes Verhältnis zu erotischen Darstellungen im öffentlichen Raum sag ich mal. Jeder der sich
mal angeguckt hat was in Pompeji zum Beispiel was sie da ausgegraben haben. Es gibt einen
Fruchtbarkeitskult der den Gott Priapos in Mittelpunkt hat. Priapos solltet ihr alle mal googlen und euch die Bilder angucken
das ist fantastisch. Priapos ist ein Gott mit einem so großen Gemächt das es auf Rädern getragen werden muss.
Also der hat einfach einen sehr großen Schwanz. Das ist also so Meter lang im im Vergleich zu zu ihm also.
Oh wow!
Das ist Priapos der Fruchtbarkeitsgott und Gemälde von Priapos hingen nicht nur in in griechische Bordellen sondern
halt auch im öffentlichen Raum. Und...
Gute Güte ich schau hier gerade auf
Bilder.. meine Herren
Ja also das ist doch das ist explizit also wir würden das heute als als explizit obszön pornographisch bezeichnen
die Griechen hatten da jetzt nicht so die Probleme damit.
Ja aber ich meine das ist jetzt aber auch schon nen bisschen ausgedacht oder gib' irgendwelche Berichte das das Ding
Naja also es gibt was wir haben ist ...
Na gut ich meine es ist ein Gott also da können sie ja viel...
Das ist richtig, aller Dings was wir haben ist
Beschützer von Vieh, Schafen und Ziegen
Ja
Ok
Ja wir haben aber natürlich Literatur und auch Gedichte aus der Zeit also wir haben römische Gedichte und und
griechische Gedichte und diese Gedichte aus der Zeit sind sehr explizit Teilweise und
zum Beispiel gibt es aus Pompeji Pompeji ist übrigens ein Ort in Italien aber es gibt da Graffiti.
Sie haben Graffiti an den an den Wänden gefunden und ich kann mal nen paar vorlesen es gibt nämlich ein wundervolles
Buch von Reclam das heißt "Glücklich ist dieser Ort" Tausend Graffiti aus Pompeji.
Also ich meine diese griechische und italienische Kultur hat sich ja da ohne hin extrem gegenseitig beeinflusst
also der Begriff kommt aus Griechenland..
Genau
und waren Schriften über Prostituierte aber ich meine war das dann so zu sagen im Sinne von "So haben sie es genannt"
und es war im Prinzip schon das was wir jetzt so unter Porno verstehen das es so sagen wir mal um erregendes
Material geht oder hatte das irgendwie son wissenschaftlichen
Nein also
Hintergrund das es jetzt
Es war anders in der Öffentlichkeit verankert es hatte nicht den gleichen Tabuwert weil also das das sieht man
einfach auch mit dem Umgang. Sie hatten relativ, wir würden sagen ein relativ modernen Umgang damit.
Also sie hatten eine Fäkalsprache die sie benutzt haben im im umgangssprachlichen Bereich das sieht man wie gesagt
an diesen an diesen Graffiti zum Beispiel
Graffiti wo?
Naja also das Niveau ich mein das ist son bisschen wie "Hier habe ich gefickt am 14. und 21. August", "Jukundus leckt
Rustikas Fotze"
Das ist jetzt wieder aus Pompeji?
Das ist Pompeji ja genau, also Fortunatus süßes Seelchen harter Stecher dies schreib wer's wissen kann, ja Medusafickmaus
und so also das sind alles so das sind Graffiti aus von von
Was zitierst du da gerade fürn Buch?
das ist dieses Tausend Graffiti aus Pompeji von Reclam, das ist ein Buch
Glücklich ist dieser Ort
Genau das hat mehrere hundert Seiten und danach kennt man alle lateinische Deklinationen von Ficken.
Kann ich nur empfehlen wundervolles Buch
stick
Ja es hat irgendwie mehrere hundert Seiten. Genau und da sind auch halt Abbildungen dieser dieser Graffiti
und es ist so das nun ja die Römer und die Griechen es gab es gab wie gesagt Gedichte die doch sehr zur Sache gingen
und die Art von von Zensur gab es zwar auch aber es war ein bisschen anders in der Gesellschaft verankert als bei uns
oder in der modernen Gesellschaft. Der moderne Begriff der Pornographie kommt tatsächlich son bisschen
aus dem 19. Jahrhundert.
Ich meine so auch diese Abbildung von Nacktheit hatte ja ich meine die ganzen Staturen der damaligen Zeit waren
nun nicht gerade besonders verhüllt hier und da mal ein Schleier aber ich meine das auch jetzt so Götter pur nackt
gezeigt wurden war ja eigentlich total Usus das war ja die Normalität.
Also ja also Sexualität hatte schon ein Raum im privaten das war schon durchaus also es war nicht so das die Leute
da durch die Straßen gingen und irgendwie sich wie jetzt beim Karneval in Köln irgendwie vögelnt in die in die
Seitengassen und so.. aber es hatte nicht dieses tabuisierte denk ich mal. Es war es war es war also die
dieser dieser Tabuwert von Pornographie den kennen wir eigentlich erst, der kommt der kommt erst später dazu weil nämlich
Pornographie hatte auch früher unterschiedliche Funktionen. Also sowohl in Griechenland als auch in in
in Rom war Pornographie bis zur Aufklärung ein ganz spezifischen Instrument der Kritik. das heißt also Obrigkeitskritik
auch Kirchenkritik wurde ganz vermehrt mit Bildern aus aus aus dem was wir heute Pornographisch nennen würden
vermengt. das heißt also wenn man wenn man zum Beispiel die katholische Kirche kritisieren wollte sagen wir
zur Zeiten zur Zeiten der Renaissance hat man das gemacht in dem man gesagt hat "Ja also in den Klöstern
da vögeln sie doch alle einander" so und das das war tatsächlich ein ein ein Kritik... eine Art Kritik zu üben
an der Obrigkeit. Das war nicht primär sich zu erregen daran, natürlich auch aber nicht primär sondern
es war mehr so dieses, sie sind obszön und sie nicht die heiligen Kirchenmänner als die sie sich ausgeben.
Ja
Also das war genau das war damals valide Kritik da.
Ok naja damit kann man die Leute natürlich immer ganz gut vom Sockel stoßen das funktioniert ja eigentlich auch heute noch ganz gut.
Genau und auch sagen naja vielleicht sind die auch mit dem Teufel im Bunde und so weil ich hab da gehört ne und so
und hier ist das Flugblatt und her ist die...
Und denkst du das das auch schon bei den Griechen so war? Weil ich meine ich weiß gar nicht wie das so ist mit Kirche und
Griechenland so ich meine da in diese Institutionalisierte Kirche in dem Sinne hatte ja dann noch nicht so den Platz.
Naja sie hatten halt ja sie hatten halt griechische Götterwelt natürlich die Entsprechung in der römischen Götterwelt fand
und wenn man sich das mal anguckt also ich mein da hat ja auch jeder mit jeden und Kinder und hier und da und dann entsprang
irgendwie hier noch ne Gottheit aus diesem Kopf...
Das stimmt
Zeus mit dem Schwan und Zeus mit dem Stier und Zeus mit so ziemlich allen und dann kam Hera mit dem Kochlöffel
naja also so.
Ging gut ab im Olymp
Jor so also die hatten da auch ich meine die durften ja auch waren ja Götter.
Ja das heißt man hatte auch eigentlich so eher ich meine das projiziert ja so zu sagen auch das eigene Gesellschaftsbild an der Stelle
wo man sich so die Götter erschafft ja mag ja manche Leute geben die glauben das das immer ist und man lernt das dann
aber sie haben es sich ja im Prinzip alles ausgedacht und dann war das ja so quasi würd mal meinen
so das Abbild auch der realen Gesellschaft in gewissen Hinsicht.
Naja sie waren da vor allen Dingen insofern bisschen frei ich mein kennst du Lysistrata von Aristophanes das ist ein eine
Komödie eine griechische Komödie und in Lysistrata geht's darum die Männer führen Krieg ich glaube es ist
irgendwie Troja gegen Athen oder so. Also jedenfalls die Männer führen Krieg gegen einander und die Frauen sagen
ah nee das ist Sparta gegen jedenfalls die Frauen der beiden verfeindeten Nationen kommen zusammen und sagen
"Das geht so nicht weiter die Männer sind weg, das geht nicht, das ist furchtbar was machen wir?" so und dann
entscheiden sie sich wir sagen wir machen jetzt so lange ein Sexstreik bis die Männer endlich zu Besinnung kommen
und diesen verfickten also diese diesen diesen Krieg einfach aufhören und das machen sie dann auch
und Lysistrata ist die Anführerin und die gehen dann auf sone Burg und sagen "So wir haben jetzt solange
keinen Sex mit euch bis ihr endlich zur Besinnung kommt." und die Männer sind natürlich also die da geht's
irgendwann nur noch darum das die Männer sagen "ich kann nicht mehr ich irgendwie son Druck also das geht nicht.".
Also da werden Euphemismen raus geholt...
Du musst das lesen es ist sehr explizit. Die Frauen natürlich sagen auch irgendwann wir können nicht mehr
wir möchten gern wieder Sex mit unsern Männer und Lysistrata ist aber eisern und sagt "Nee" und die müssen sich dann auch so
also manche schleichen sich dann so heimlich außen aus dem Schloss da raus und so um ihre Männer und sagen
dann aber auch "Nein erst muss der Krieg aufhören dann kannste wieder ran und so." und die Männer sind irgendwann
so verzweifelt das sie sagen "Ok.. alles alles was ihr sagt aber BITTE BITTE kommt in unsere Schlafzimmer zurück." und
damit ist dann der Krieg beendet.
Wow
Also ja es ist...
Ob das heute auch noch funktionieren würde?
JEDERZEIT!
Ok
Ich würd sagen schon.
Ok also das heißt diese Schriften über die Prostituierten hatten keinen wissenschaftlichen Grund so wenn's Kritik allein ist
weiß ich nicht. Ich meine das ist es wird doch dann schon auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch son Unterhaltungsromanfunktion
Ja
gehabt haben oder?
Also in... was man halt wissen muss ist das wir aus unserer Sicht so zu sagen, wir haben ja so ein bisschen so ein viktorianisches
Erbe das heißt also es gibt Wörterbuchdefinitionen die tatsächlich diese griechische Etymologie heranziehen
aber zum Beispiel jetzt im 19. Jahrhundert hat dieses Schriften über Prostitution wieder den ursprünglichen diese ursprüngliche
diese ursprüngliche Bedeutung nämlich vor allen Dingen im Zuge Hygiene und Stadtentwicklung
und wir müssen den armen Frauen helfen und so.
hmhm
Also das genau das das gab's dann auch.
Also wenn ich das jetzt noch mal richtig zusammenfasse: also in Griechenlang ging's irgendwie los da kam auch der Begriff her
hmhm
wie so vieles und machte sich das in ähnlichen auch im im im römischen Universum breit einschließlich dieses Begriffs?
Ja
Das heißt der wurde da wie so viele andere Begriffe übernommen und es wurde dann auch im Wesentlichen genauso betrieben
also waren's da so zu sagen immer noch die Schriften über die Prostituierten war das überhaupt primär Schriften oder
Es war
gab’s dann auch schon so pornographische Shows oder so keine Ahnung ich meine wie Peepshow irgendwie
Naja also es gab ja es gab ja vor allen Dingen auch Kaiser und die römische Dekadenz ja also die viel zitierte
Spätrömisch
Die Spätrömische Dekadenz genau
Nein aber es gab zum Beispiel Caligula, der ja bekannt dafür ist das er tatsächlich ausschweifende Orgien und so gefeiert hat
aber das war tatsächlich das Vorrecht der herrschenden Klassen.
hmhm
Das heißt also Ausschweifungen und auch der der Konsum dieser Schriften war natürlich erst mal musste man in irgendeiner Form
des schriftlichen mächtig sein und man musste schreiben und lesen können und man musste auch die Zeit haben sowohl das eine
zu verfassen als auch das zu lesen. Das heißt erotische Schriften oder Schriften mit sexuellen expliziten Inhalten
war immer in irgendeiner Form so der der ja den herrschenden Klassen vorbehalten eine ganz ganz lange Zeit.
Eigentlich hat erst der Film das wirklich beendet.
hmhm
Es gab in der in der Renaissance gab es einen Mann der hieß Piedro Aretino und der war der erste der von sich gesagt hat
er ist Pornograph.
Piedro
Aretino
Aretino war ein tja was war er, er hat geschrieben, er stand auch unter dem besonderen Schutz der italienischen Staatsmacht
und er war tatsächlich jemand der sich sehr viele Freiheiten genommen hat und Aretino hat ist bekannt geworden
dadurch das er Kupferstiche kommentiert hat und mit Sonetten versehen hat und diese Kupferstiche das waren
11 Posen 11 sexuelle Posen die son bisschen ja son bisschen erinnerten an das Kamasutra also es waren
es waren explizierte Posen nackter Körper.
hmhm
Und er hat diese Posen mit Sonetten versehen.
Also Kamasutra ist diese indische
Ja
Sexaktdarstellungs....
Ja es ist vor allen Dingen eine eine Lehre über das Wesen der Sexualität.
hmhm
Also es hatte ein also das Kamasutra ein pädagogischen Hintergrund son bisschen auch also einen Lehrenden Hintergrund.
Ok können wir gleich noch mal drauf eingehen.
Es ist die Kunst der Sexualität.
Also Aretino hat jetzt so Kupferstiche die ja eben auch so entsprechende Geschlechtsakte so zu sagen zeigten kommentiert
Nja mit Sonetten versehen genau und wie er diese Kupferstiche gemacht hat also die Leute die diese Kupferstiche gemacht
haben, der Zeichner und der Mensch der diese Stiche tatsächlich gemacht hat die sind in irgendwelchen Kerkern verschwunden
Aretino hatte das Glück das ihm das nicht wiederfahren ist und deswegen ist Aretino auch der Mensch zu dem
diese diese Posen auch dem die zugeschrieben werden.
hmhm
Und diese Posen sind insofern Weltberühmt geworden weil sie in das in das populäre Wissen dieser damaligen Gesellschaft
übergegangen sind das heißt jeder Mann kannte diese Posen und das merkt man daran, es gibt Assias darüber
es gibt Gemälde die völlig andere Dinge darstellen aus aus einer Zeit nen bisschen später Aretino hat gelebt im 15. Jahrhundert
die Gemälde sind teilweise außen außen 17. 18. Jahrhundert und in diesen Gemälden werden seine Posen rezipiert
das heißt es gibt ein Gemälde da ist ein siegreicher König und ein unterlegender König und dieser unterlegende König
ist in exakt der gleichen Pose wie die erste Pose von von Aretino also das ist die gleiche Handhaltung die gleiche die gleiche
Darstellung das heißt...
Was für was für Posen sind das so?
Ich kann dir das mal zeigen ich habe das ich habe das hier.
Du musst das natürlich beschreiben.
Ich muss das beschreiben genau, also es sind eigentlich wie man sich das so vorstellt eine Frau liegt auf einem Mann
hmhm
es ist alles sehr ja also sehr fleischlich, sie sind nackt natürlich für uns wäre das jetzt keine große Sache
Aber für damalige Verhältnisse war das schon.
Es war halt nackt und sie haben halt Sex und man sieht einen erigierten Schwanz also das ist man sieht halt schon
das was man sehen muss
So hier zum Beispiel also sie liegt irgendwie nur noch mit den Schultern auf einem Kissenberg,
hat auch also ich weiß nicht ihr Gesichtsausdruck ist irgendwo zwischen entrückt, transzendental und oh ich fall hier gleich runter
hm
er hat also er steht irgendwie breitbeinig weil sonst verliert er nämlich das Gleichgewicht hat ihre hat ihre Kniekehlen
umfasst, ihr eines Bein was irgendwie so nach oben gen Himmel gereckt und müht sich halt sichtlich irgendwie sein sein
Gleichgewicht nicht zu verlieren. So das ist halt die also das ist die 11. die 11. Pose. Hier ist zum Beispiel das ist die 1. Pose
die 1. Pose ist man sieht die Frau von hinten sie hat ihre Hand, also die sind sehr muskulös immer beide Menschen
sind sehr muskulös
Jaja
ihre Hand ist in soner in soner gebeugten Stellung man sieht sehr gut ihren Po und ihren ihren Oberschenkel
der sich so rumwickelt um den Oberschenkel des Mannes und sie sind in soner Umarmung. Also das ist sehr liebevoll ja
und das ist, wir würden das jetzt auch gar nicht als so dramatisch empfinden.
Aber die Posen sind sagen wir mal so, sehr eingängig wenn man sie mal gesehen hat
Genau
so dann wird man sie auch immer wieder entdecken wenn sie dann später zitiert werden.
Und hier sieht man, hier sieht man also ich beschreib das jetzt mal. Das ist ein Bild, das ist der der christliche König
viel unter Pavia, da hat irgendwie König Pavia wohl offensichtlich gewonnen, König Pavia ist aufen Pferd
und hier der christliche König ist hier unten und man sieht er die exakt gleiche Pose wie die Frau in Aretinos erster Pose.
Also die Hand ist exakt so angewinkelt, das Bein auch wieder, der muskulöse Hintern
Verstehe
So und das Männer die Aretinos Posen kannten, konnten das natürlich identifizieren. Das ist natürlich, der König wurde hier
als Frau dargestellt und das war in der sexistischen Gesellschaft dieser Zeit die unterlegende Pose.
Hm, verstehe
Hah ist eine kulturelle Konsultation
hm
Genau, und deswegen kann man davon ausgehen das das Männer in der Zeit einfach alles kannten, weil sonst hätte man
das so nicht malen müssen wenn das keiner versteht die Referenz also wenn das zu Inn ist versteht das ja keiner.
Jetzt haben wir ja eigentlich nen relativ großen Sprung gemacht von den Römern bin in die Renaissance
Naja dazwischen liegt das Mittelalter.
Das Mittelalter ist generell eigentlich extrem uncool oder?
Das Mittelalter ist extrem uncool. Also man weiß auch in der Pornographie Forschung gibt’s unglaublich wenig Material
zum Mittelalter man weiß nur die Kirche stand über allem, die Kirche hat auch alles getötet was in irgendeiner Form
in irgendeiner Form obszön und so und Leute die, wie gesagt also Aretino im 15. Jahrhundert das war
ich mein da war ja die Kirche auch sehr sehr dominant und sie sind alle eingekerkert worden und so bis auf
einige wenige Menschen aber da hat nicht viel überlebt sagen wir mal so.
Das heißt die Renaissance war auch unter anderem eine Renaissance dieser Kultur.
Ja genau.
Ein gesellschaftlicher Aufbruch.
Genau und es gab, kennst du den Film Team Amerika? Das ist
Ja
Das ist ja ein populärer Film, ein animierter Film
ja genau Fuck Yeah - und da gibt es eine Szene die ich unglaublich schön fand
Fuck Yeah
und zwar, sind sie da in so einer Bar und da geht’s darum um um Pussies, Dicks und Assholes so dieses irgendwie
"Dicks fuck pussies and they fuck assholes too, so it's better to be a dick than a pussy" und das hat mir so sehr gefallen
weil das ist eine eine eine Referenz auf eine Schrift aus ich glaube Verona in der in der Renaissance
also das ist eine Renaissanceschrift, die da zitiert wird.
hm
Da ging's um einen Stadtstaat, ich bilde mir ein das war Verona ich kann mich da aber auch irren.
Ja
Und die Adlige Klasse wurde tatsächlich also es wurde tatsächlich so kritisiert es gab die Adligen und es gab den Klerus
und es gab die Bürger und da wurde mit genau dieser Metaphern Welt also mit die einen sind die Pussies, die andern sind die Diggs
und die dritten sind die Assholes wurde da gearbeitet und ich weiß nicht ob die Macher wahrscheinlich wussten die das nicht
aber das ist eine uralte Referenz gewesen und das hat mich sehr gefreut die da zu finden.
Also wenn die so zutreffen dann liegt’s natürlich schon sehr nahe das dann auch in irgendeiner Form daher kommt.
Aber das ja schon ne sehr obskure Referenz, ich glaube auch nicht das das irgendwie dieser Zusammenhang bisher
in weiten Kreisen bekannt war.
Ok, naja gut bis zum Beweis des Gegenteils kann man ja erst mal davon ausgehen das es vielleicht eine war. Zumindest
hat sie zugetroffen ich meine insofern habe sie es zitiert ob sie bewusst gemacht haben oder nicht.
Es ist immer noch aktuell offensichtlich ja also das heißt das das auch die die Religionskritik durch
pornographische oder durch sexuell explizite Vergleiche hat immer noch eine Daseinsberechtigung, ja.
Aber würdest du sagen das jetzt auch noch in der Renaissance so primär die Pornographie wirklich so kritikgetrieben war?
Also Aretinos Posen markieren son bisschen den Anfang von sexuell explizite Darstellung zur Erotisierung.
Aber immer nur von der Erotisierung einer einer kleinen Kaste oder Klasse also man musste halt Zugriff auf diese Stiche
haben oder auf die Zeichnung die diesen Stichen zu Grunde liegen, man musste lesen können, das konnten nicht nicht alle
(hm)
und es immer so ein bisschen ein Vergnügen der Adligen oder der ja es gab ja da noch kein
Bürgertum an sich.
Andererseits hatten die ja nun eigentlich auch keinen Mangel an Zugriff auf Prostituierte.
Richtig
Fragt man sich ob, was dann sozusagen der Bedarf für die Pornographie noch war. War das einfach nur so weil sie nicht genug kriegen
konnten oder?
Na weil sie konnten und weil sie die Zeit hatten, also das ganze erlebt ja noch mal sone sone ganze Blüte ..sone ganz große Blütezeit
in der Libertinage das war dann ein bisschen später weil es ist ja immer so gewesen wenn du Adlig warst dann hattest du ja
nicht wirklich du musstest nicht arbeiten für dein Geld du hattest irgendwie nicht viel zu tun ja und was machst du
wenn du nicht viel zu tun hast, du denkst halt irgendwie an Schweinkram.
Was, was, was also was verstehst du unter Libertinage?
Libertinage war der das war der Adel also der war der französische Adel so de Sade gehörte dazu und
aber de Sade ist schon ein bisschen später.
Der Marquis de Sade
(hmm)
und die Libertinage hat tatsächlich sich mit einer Werft diesem diesem diesem Literarischen Genre
der Sexualität und und der pornographischen Beschreibung also die haben da echt drauf geworfen und da gib's
ganz ganz viele Texte pornographische Texte die auch wirklich der Erotisierung des Lesers ja also
die das bezwecken sollten.
(hmm)
Und deswegen also die hatten einfach auch echt mal die Zeit so.
Ja gut ich mein ja jetzt kommen wir ja auch dann so langsam in die Zeit des des des Buchdruckts und und
genau
und der Möglichkeit solche Geschichten überhaupt erst zu vervielfältigen und dann auch in Massen zu
konsumieren.
Wobei die Massen immer noch die Massen der der der Adeligen also es ging immer noch
Es war nicht jeder Mann aber es war so zu sagen jetzt nicht so es gab nur den einen der den Kupferstich hatte
Ja genau genau
sondern es gab das schon in nennenswerteren Mengen und wurden Romane geschrieben etc. was ja so vorher
auch nicht in der Menge stattfand.
Und es gab zum ersten mal auch Leute die sich tatsächlich damit systematisch auseinander gesetzt haben und den Scheiß
auch gesammelt haben. Also da war ein Mann hat sich da sehr sehr hervor getan der hieß Henry Spencer Ashbee
der war, das war ein Engländer und Ashbee hat Pornographie gesammelt.
(ehe)
Der hatte eine riesige Bibliothek die natürlich nach seinem Tot sofort vernichtet worden ist aber sofort und der hat halt
Indizes heraus gegeben. Also der hat so zu sagen seine Bibliothek indiziert und hat diese Indizes mit
ja mit Beschreibungen so von wegen ich mach das aus Selbstlosigkeit damit ihr das nicht mehr lesen müsst so
und hat das dann beschrieben worum's in diesen einzelnen Büchern ging und ob die was taugen und so. Also er hat nicht son
Fabindex oder so gemacht sondern mehr so es hat jetzt literarisch nicht so den Wert und naja son bisschen. Aber Ashbee
war so der der erste krasse Pornographienerd der das richtig gesammelt und und seine Indizes sind fantastisch also die sind
ganz liebevoll gemacht und er hat sich wirklich jedes Buch das er hatte vorgenommen und wirklich ganz sorgfältig rezensiert
und und so das war schon echt schön.
Das ist jetzt schon so 19. Jahrhundert, das heißt grundsätzlich über die ganze Zeit jetzt von der Renaissance
bis dann so neue Medien dazu kamen Pornographie war im wesentlichen Romane, Geschichten, Gedichte
du weißt das der Roman also der Roman als als Genregattung den gib’s erst seit dem 18. Jahrhundert.
Ok
Das heißt das waren vorher keine Romane es gab vorher gab es so dialogische dialogische Szenen ja der Roman
an sich den gib’s ja erst
Ok
tatsächlich im 18. .. ja 18. Jahrhundert.
Oder waren's dann doch mehr schon Abbildungen und Zeichnungen?
Das na das ging immer Hand in Hand natürlich weil es waren also Abbildungen an sich auch Kontextlos
aber natürlich war das das interessantere für mich von der Forschung her sind natürlich immer die Bücher.
Ja gut aber es gab auch so gedruckte Werke
Ja natürlich!
Na was weiß ich, ich hab da ja nicht gelebt!
Ja ich auch nicht.
Ich hab da auch kein ich hab da auch kein Archiv von so ne aber ich frag mich so ne wie das so ist also ist es so zu sagen
immer noch so wie schon früher so man hat da so diese so diese Abbildung bei Aretino so zu sagen die Posen
ja so 8 Kupferstiche und so und die starten einen die ganze Zeit an und die sind so so so beeindruckend das sie dann eben
auch zitiert werden so quasi als eigenes Mem kann man ja im Prinzip sagen
Ja genau es ist eins der erstem Mem's ja
Als Mem sich dann so so durch zieht
So habe ich das noch gar nicht betrachtet.
Jaja ist es aber eigentlich.
Jaja natürlich ja
und dann wenn man so zu sagen mit Büchern reproduzieren kann würde ich ja erwarten das dann eben alle angefangen haben
auf einmal solche Szenerien zu malen, sind das dann auch so Geschichten oder sind das so zu sagen so weitere Posen Sammlungen
und nur neue und so?
Naja...
Also erzählt geht das schon so so in Richtung Porno-Comicbook das da wirklich sone Geschichte erzählt wird oder
ist das einfach so Posen Sammlung?
Nee nee also bei Aretino ging es vor allen Dingen erst mal um die Darstellung eines sexuellen Aktes das war das Revolutionäre,
das war das Tabuisierte, das gab’s nicht.
(ehem)
Und das war auch das was die Kirche gern verhindern wollte das überhaupt Sexualität das war was das hat man gemacht
damit Kinder kommen ja, für die Kirche ganz, ich meine das ist ja immer noch so.
Aber warum geht denn eigentlich die Kirche da so drauf ab auf das Thema? Ich meine was ist eigentlich so schlimm daran?
Naja es ist halt nen Ausdruck von also wenn man Sex gut findet und genießt das ist ein Ausdruck von Hedonismus und das geht nur
das darfst das also ich mein die, gerade die Kirche damals in der Renaissance also Extase darf man bitte schön nur im Gottesdienst haben
und nur wenn es Gott gewidmet ist ja und das also das man das man so Extase und so in nem sexuellen Akt das das war das hat ja
auch son bisschen was heidnisches also das geht auf die Dionysien dann wieder zurück diese also auch diese diese
Bakosfeste und und die Dionysien im römischen dann das also das das geht son bisschen auf son heidnischen
genießen von Wein, Weib und Gesang zurück das in der Kirche das das war ja in der katholischen Kirche sehr verpönt natürlich
also Extase bitte nur auf Gott bezogen.
Aber so bei den Katholiken geht’s ja auch eigentlich schon
Ja ja aber das ist alles nur wenn das sanktioniert ist also Karneval war sone sanktionierte also so eine eine "ihr dürft jetzt mal einmal im Jahr"
Einmal dürft ihr euch jetzt mal richtig schön frei...
Genau
Frei ficken irgendwie und dann ist wieder gut.
Genau aber nur wenn sie die also sobald dann Kontrollverlust war über die über die Bilder und das Verhalten und so
und das war ja auch, man hat ja man hat ja moralisches Verhalten definiert ne, also du musst irgendwie ehrbar und moralisch und
Sexualität ist was das das hat bitte schön im Privaten und Geheimen eigentlich nicht im Privaten sondern im Geheimen
statt zu finden und da gab’s ja auch fest feste Rollen also der Mann war immer irgendwie zumindest aus Sicht der Kirche
ne also Frauen hatten bitte schön Sex gar nicht zu genießen das ging nicht und es gab ja also ich mein die Missionarsstellung
hat ja auch unter anderem deshalb diesen Namen das war also das war die so zu sagen ja das war die Stellung
die man halt so haben durfte, ja Mann oben Frau unten mehr gib’s nicht Punkt.
(ehem)
So, Kinder.. das war’s. Spaß machen.. eh eh.. das war das kam ja gar nicht vor...
(hm)
Und Aretinos Posen zum Beispiel zeigten ja auch mal einfach andere Stellungen und andere das auch vielleicht Spaß machen könnte und so
Und es war jetzt auch gar nicht so ne nen Ausdruck von männlicher Dominanz im weitesten Sinne oder?
Ja naja also da die rezep... also die Rezeption dieser Posen war ja irgendwie eigentlich nur männlich und auch das das
Frauen haben haben sich ja mit Pornographie oder Sexualität eigentlich ganz selten befasst das war ja nicht schicklich und es gab
auch keine Kultur in der Frauen das tun konnten. Also Frauen haben sich damals vor allen Dingen mit den Folgen von Sexualität beschäftigt
also mit dem Kinderkriegen und Midwifery also so Hebammen und und hinaus. Sexualität an sich war den Männern vorbehalten
oder beziehungsweise die der Genuss der Sexualität ja...
(hmm)
Und und auch der Rezeption von irgendwie sexuell konnotierten Werkern ne, also bei Frauen haben sie ja schon gekuckt
wenn der Roma aus aus Frankreich kam dann war das ja schon eine liederliche Person ja da da ging noch gar nicht noch nicht mal
darum worum’s in den Roman überhaupt ging aber ne Frauen im viktorianischen Zeitalter die
französische Romane lesen das war nicht gut.
Also allein schon das lesen eines Romans war an sich...
Aus Frankreich ja, alles was aus Frankreich kam war irgendwie versaut.
Wie der Markie de Sade
Wie der Markie de Sade ja der war allerdings sehr spezifisch.
Ja was ist denn mit dem ich mein das ist doch derjenige der den Begriff Sadismus quasi
Ja kennst du von ihm Texte?
Nö
Ok der Markie de Sade hat eine sehr eine sehr spezifische Vorstellung von Sexualität gehabt
man sagt ja auch also bei ihm in seinem Haushalt kam zuerst die Kinder aus der Nachtbarschaft dann seine Pferde
irgendwann mal die weiblichen Dienstboten und ganz am Ende seine Frau die dann auch immer irgendwie
sich um die Kolateralschäden dieser Sexualität kümmern musste.
(ehem)
Er wurde dann ja auch eingesperrt, er hat ja irgendwie der Legende her Romane dann mit seinem eigenen Blut
und debastie geschrieben und so weiter. Also der war eine sehr sag ich mal spezifische Persönlichkeit auf dem Gebiet
der Pornographie allerdings auch wieder ein typisches Kinder seiner Zeit weil die Pornographie in der Zeit
in der er gelebt hat war tatsächlich eigentlich nur ein systematisches überschreiten der Moral seiner Gesellschaft.
Also da ging’s gar nicht unbedingt darum jetzt sexuell anregende Dinge zu beschreiben, vielleicht für ihn ja
aber es ging vor allen Dingen um den Tabubruch. Das heißt er hat Dinge beschrieben die tabuisiert waren in seiner Gesellschaft
und schon allein über Sex zu schreiben war ja ein Tabu aber dann so explizit also diese Gewaltorgien und
dieses systematische missbrauchen von allem was auch in unserer Gesellschaft noch tabuisiert ist also der Sex mit Kinder,
der Sex mit Tieren das das war für ihn also das das hat er systematisch auch alles aufgeschrieben und sehr detailliert
Hat der das nur geschrieben oder hat der das auch wirklich getan?
Ja sowohl als auch also man es ist so die Überlieferung, natürlich weiß man’s nicht so genau
Ja
aber es gibt Briefe die nahe legen das er tatsächlich auch teilweise gelebt hat was er geschrieben hat ja.
Wow
Also er war ein, aber das ist halt die französische also er war ein ein Teil des französischen Adels der
ja der sich halt diesem hingegeben hat.
Ok.
Und es spiegelt sich auch in Teilen viktorianischer Literatur das ist ein bisschen später da geht es auch ganz ganz viel
um diese um diesen Tabubruch weil also in der in der viktorianischen Gesellschaft 19. Jahrhundert sind wir jetzt.
Ist das ja auch so das8äh) Frauen haben kein Sexualleben also es gibt also den Frauen wird der Trieb abgesprochen
und bei den Männer ist das auch so sittlich natürlich gemäßigt also Mäßigung ist so dass das Wort der Stunde ne das Wort des Jahrhunderts
und es gibt aber Gentelmanclubs die auch son bis.. nen gewissen anrüchigen Ruf haben und aus diesen Gentelmanclubs
kommen halt auch pornographische Werke und und Pornographie.
Also Gentelmanclubs so zu sagen so Clubs
Herrenclubs
die halt nur Männern vorbehalten waren
Männer auch wieder aus den aus den höheren Gesellschaftsschichten
Ja
und die hatten tatsächlich auch die mussten auch nicht arbeiten
Gibt‘s ja auch heute noch ne...
Das gib’s auch heute noch aber ob die sich jetzt irgendwie vor allen Dingen den also, Pornographie hat heut zu tage ne andere
Naja gut ich bezog mich jetzt auch nur auf die Clubs nicht auf ihren Umgang mit Pornographie aber ich
Ne ne
weiß ja ehrlich gesagt nichts bin bin in keinem, ich war auch noch in keinem
Ahja naja ja ja dafür in Nerdclubs
Also ich streite alles ab auf jeden Fall...
Ok ok
Also sie haben gesagt ich darf nicht drüber reden
Alles klar
Ok Herrenclubs ok das war so zu sagen so so son neuer Trend im viktorianischen Zeitalter.
Ja und und viktorianische Pornographie wenn man die liest (me) da geht’s auch nicht darum in irgendeiner Form besonders erotische
Momente oder besonders anreizende Momente darzustellen sondern es geht vor allen Dingen um die Quantität also es gibt ein Buch
das heißt My Secret Life, My Secret Life ist eine Art Tagebuch von dem nicht ganz geklärt werden kann ist das jetzt ein Fake
oder ist das wirklich ein Tagebuch von nem englischen Gentleman
(ehem)
und es hat auch offiziell keinen Autor man weiß nicht wer es geschrieben hat Ashbee ist einer so der Kandidaten
der es geschrieben haben könnte.
Der mit dem Index.
(ehem)
Aber es ist letzten Endes geht es darum es sind 11 lange lange lange Ausgaben also dicke Bücher, 11 Stück
mysteriöse Flecken wie gesagt und da geht’s halt wirklich nur darum wann er wie, wo, mit wem und so weiter
und das ist eigentlich ne quantitative Aufzählung und in dieser quantitativen Aufzählung wird auch ganz klar das es eigentlich
um die um dieses Tabubrechen geht also da wird jede Stellung wird mindestens einmal aufgeführt tatsächlich der Vollständigkeit halber.
Ja
Also Sex mit allen möglichen Gesellschaftsschichten, mit allen möglichen Altersstufen, mit Tieren, mit Toten es wird alles einmal
aufgezählt.
Mit Toten?
Hach mit Gegenständen mit allem es wird einmal alles probiert so.
Oh
Es wird gekuckt ist es irgendwie spannend Frauen beim kacken zu zukucken und so
es wird einfach alles einmal beschrieben so und da geht’s jetzt nicht darum ob das besonders sexuell attraktive ist oder oder geil
oder so sondern es wird einfach nur einmal alles aufgelistet. Weil man durfte da drüber nicht reden. Es war kein Teil der offiziellen
des offiziellen Gesellschaftsdiskurs.
Ja
Also war es tabuisiert also wurde es aufgeschrieben.
(ehem)
So und es gibt ich meine der hat es war eins dieser Bücher da geht’s echt nur darum wie er mit mit irgendwie 15, 16 sich irgendwie
über irgendwelche Aborte also der stellt sich dann in irgendwelche Kellerfenster und kuck Frauen beim kacken zu.
So ja und und so also dis...seitenlange Beschreibungen... Wahnsinn...
Wow
Also so detailliert habe ich das bisher nie wieder gelesen.
Ok aber auch so jenseits solcher Ausrisse geht’s im Wesentlichen dann doch eher um Sex?
Ja es geht um Sex und es auch darum, was macht man denn was sind denn so die Konsequenzen von Sex
das finde ich ganz interessant weil man sagt ja immer Pornographie findet in sonem parallel Universum statt
wo es außer beschwerdefreiem Sex nichts gibt und alle wollen es und wollen immer und so. Viktorianischer Porn
ist ein bisschen anders weil da geht’s auch tatsächlich darum dann ist die Frau halt mal Schwanger geworden, was macht man
denn jetzt damit
(ehem)
So oder dann hat er halt mal Syphilis gekriegt und oder andere mysteriöse Krankheiten die er nicht selber einordnen
konnte das war dann irgendwie Tripper oder solche Geschichten und
(ehem)
das hat er alles auch sehr sehr explizit in dieses Buch rein geschrieben also es ist gar nicht wirklich
jetzt sagen wir mal aufgeilend wenn er dann beschreibt wie ihm dann da Dinge an seinem Penis wachsen
die er da nicht haben will und so und was er dann damit macht und wer ihm das wohlmöglicher weise verpasst haben könnte und so.
Wow
Das ist alles also das ist alles eher nichts was wir mit momentan als pornographisch noch beschreiben würden
oder was wir inkludieren würden in in modernen Pornofilmen zum Beispiel.
Seh grad, gib’s auch komplett zum Runterladen als PDF.
Jap.
Ok
Ist ja auch gemeinfrei also es ist zwar ein verwaistes Werk aber älter als 70 Jahre ne von daher
Ja.
Go for it. Also man sollte zumindest mal durch skippen das ist ganz lustig vor allen Dingen auch weil es sehr sehr viel
über die damalige Organisation von Gesellschaft erzählt.
Ok aber es jetzt sagen wir mal nur ein Ausriss und nicht unbedingt der typische Vertreter dessen was sich jetzt
im viktorianischen Zeitalter so entwickelt hat ich meine jetzt werden sie im Gentelmansclub ja nicht die ganze Zeit
in diesem Buch rumgeblättert haben oder?
Ich weiß es nicht aber es gibt auch so Monatszeitschriften da ging’s also, gerade in England gab’s so Monatszeitschriften
die beschäftigt die haben sich nur mit Span King beschäftigt. Span King ist ein Fetisch der irgendwie offensichtlich bei den Briten
ganz besonders beleibt war in der Zeit und also es kommt halt es kommt halt
Also Span King ist.. hauen, schlagen, bevorzugt aufen Hintern.
Nja ero... vor allen erotisierte erotisiertes erotisierte körperliche Züchtigung.
Ok
so würde ich das jetzt mal beschreiben.
Ja
Also Züchtigung zu
Sex mit schlagen
Jor jor genau
Das war Populär?
Das war extrem Populär.
Warum?
Da fragst du mich was leichteres
Na
Es ist halt also es war ja auch eine also körperliche Züchtigung ist ja auch tatsächlich eine also ich meine
da wären wir jetzt wieder bei Freud und so ne aber es war ein Populärer Fetisch.
Ok
Es ja auch immer noch ein populärer Fetisch so ist das nicht aber es war es füllte halt echt ganze ganze Monatszeitschriften.
Also es gab so zu sagen auch schon sowas wie Monatszeitschriften die sich im wesentlichen pornographisch
(ehem)
orientiert haben ist ja dann auch schon mal was neues.
Ja also weil wie gesagt also das das 19. Jahrhundert hat uns eigentlich diesen modernen Pornographie Begriff beschert.
Zumindest in Britannien?
Nee so in Europa würd ich sagen. Also weil im 19. Jahrhundert kommen wir dann auch zu so ersten Definitionsversuchen
die halt die wir als als modern bezeichnen würden, also da geht’s halt darum das Pornographie dann umschreiben wird mit
Darstellung des Obszönen ja, Darstellung des Unsittlichen.
(hmm)
Das geht ja sehr weit weg von diesem Schreiben von über Prostituierte ne, also schreiben über Prostituierte beinhaltete
ja auch diese ganze Hygiene Geschichte und so und dieses Obszöne das das ist tatsächlich son bisschen
die Erfindung des 19. Jahrhunderts und deren Sittlichkeitsvorstellungen und deren Moralvorstellungen auch.
Da gab’s dann da gab’s dann auch erste also diese diese Geschichte der Pornographie ist ja auch ne ganz eng
verbunden mit der Geschichte der Zensur natürlich.
Ja
Weil Zensur auch es wurde ja auch natürlich sehr viel zensiert und einkassiert und im 19. Jahrhundert gab es glaub ich
die größten und und systematischen Bestrebungen von Zensur die jetzt nicht mehr nur alleine von der Kirche
also es gab keine religiöse Zensur sondern eine staatliche Zensur danach.
Das heißt jetzt gab’s so diesen diesen Wandel hin so ne vorher hat es irgendwie Kritik ausgedrückt oder war zumindest
son Spielball für wenige Eliten und jetzt sind wir ja wirklich in der Zeit wo Schriften immer weiter verbreitet wurden
und es bei Leibe nicht nur einer Klasse vorbehalten wurden und dann änderte sich das Bild so Pornographie
ist jetzt im zunehmenden Maße schlicht die Darstellung von sexuellen Vorlieben, sexuellen Akten
Nja es war alles
zum unterhalten, zum weiß ich nicht.
Auch nicht immer also der Obszönitätsbegriff im 19. Jahrhundert ist immer noch sehr sehr breit, ist auch inkludiert auch immer noch Dinge
die wir jetzt mittlerweile als nicht mehr obszön beschreiben würden zum Beispiel damals war immer noch obszön "Aufklärung"
wenn es darum ging wie Frauen verhindern Kinder zu kriegen. Das was wir als Aufklärung bezeichnen sexuelle Aufklärung
das war damals obszön das durftest du nicht verbreiten, das durftest du nicht mit der Post schicken das war damals
sehr sehr tabuisiert und es gab im im 19. Jahrhundert gab es halt ein Gesetz das heißt das du du durftest
diese diese Dinge auch nicht mit der Post schicken und es gab einen Menschen nach dem auch bestimmte Gesetzte
benannt sind.
Man durfte Pornos nicht mit der Post schicken?
Ja das war ein amerikanisches Gesetz. Also in Amerika durfte man Garnichts das war ja sowieso ich mein Amerika hat ja auch eine
eine sehr spezialisierte Geschichte mit den mit den Puritanern.
(hmm)
Aber man durfte in Amerika obszöne Dinge nicht mit der Post schicken und das war son bisschen ein Loop hole
weil man hat natürlich versucht die Ausbreitung pornographischer und obszöner Schriften zu verhindern oder einzudämmen
und es war aber nicht so einfach weil man konnte natürlich also man hat halt immer Razzien gemacht auch bei
bei Buchhändlern und so von denen man das wusste aber das war alles nicht so Zielführend so und man hat dann halt festgestellt
viel von dem kommt einfach aus Europa und aus Frankreich vor allen Dingen.
Ach
Und deswegen hat man sich gedacht, aha wir verbieten das jetzt einmal das man das mit der Post schicken darf und dann
kann man halt da relativ systematisch zumindest die Einfuhr von obszönen Schriften verhindern.
Also alles was aus Europa und speziell aus Frankreich kommt wird einfach mal rein gekuckt.
Genau oder das das überhaupt einfach mal rein gekuckt wurde
Ja
und das also und es gab einen einen Menschen der so zu sagen die Beauftragung hatte diese Zensurmaßnahmen
durch zu führen der hieß Anthony Comstock und die Comstock laws waren aber letzten Endes viel viel weitergehend
und viel einschneidender als jetzt tatsächlich seine ursprüngliche Befugnis und Beauftragung. Anthony Comstock
hat sich echt in seinem Leben dem Kampf gegen alles obszöne verschrieben und er hatte nen sehr Breiten
Obszönitätsbegriff also er hat zum Beispiel eine Vendetta geführt gegen Abtreibungs also gegen Menschen
die Abtreibungen vorgenommen haben
(ehem)
und er hat sich immer damit gebrüstet das er mehrere Dutzend Leute in den Selbstmord getrieben hat die er tatsächlich
so vehement verfolgt hat das sie keine andere Möglichkeit gesehen haben als sich als sich selber als sich umzubringen
im Gefängnis dann meistens und also er hat gegen gegen sexuelle Aufklärung gekämpft Magarete Senge zum Beispiel
das war allerdings da war er schon sehr sehr alt aber auch gegen gegen Menschen die Abtreibungen vorgenommen haben
natürlich gegen gegen pornographische Schriften und pornographische Bilder und er hat einfachdiesen diesen irren
naja er wollte das irgendwie so sauber halten, Amerika sauber halten.
Ja, naja ich meine ist ja haben wir ja jetzt auch wieder Netzsperren und so weiter... ne. Der ganze Schmutz im Internet
darf nicht aus ungesicherten Ländern genau Stoppschilder etc. jaja History repeating.
Das heißt das war so zu sagen dann auch so der explizite Ausdruck der ganzen Prüderie der sich dann eben
auch sofort wieder auf Gesetzesebene wiederfand. War das auch gab’s das auch schon vorher das das so im eigentlichen Sinne
verboten war oder war das immer nur so geächtet und deswegen hat's keiner gemacht also war das so zu sagen
das erste Mal das jetzt so ein Antipornogesetz wirklich existiert hat?
Nee nee also es war das es gesellschaftlich in irgendeiner Form geduldet war war’s ja eigentlich seit ja seit der Dominanz
der christlichen Kirche nicht, so und da war das ja das war so die als als die katholische Kirche tatsächlich irgendwie in Gesellschaften
einen dominanten Stand hatte
War sie quasi das Gesetzt ja.
Ab dann war sie das Gesetz und irgendwann ging das auch als die Dominanz der Kirche nicht mehr so stark war aber die
weltlichen Gesetze mehr Einfluss hatten auf die Gesellschaft gab es dann natürlich auch immer Gesetze gegen Pornographie.
(hmm)
So und in in unterschiedlichen Gesellschaften unterschiedliche Gesetze aber es war immer schwierig Pornographie
zu definieren also die legale Definition oder die rechtliche Definition von Pornographie ist extrem schwierig bis heute.
Also es gibt niemand der jetzt wirklich für das Gesetz, es gibt Pornographie Definitionen auf
in Gesetzen aber die ist sehr schwammig also da gib’s ja diesen ganz ganz bekannten Aus(äh)druck von von einem
einem amerikanischen Richter der hieß Potter Stewart und der meinte I know it when I see it.
Und das ist so ein bisschen so ein geflügeltes Wort weil für jeden natürlich das was für dich Erotik ist, ist für mich Pornographie ne.
Ja
Also es ist ganz ganz schwierig zu definieren wo fängt Pornographie an und wo hört Pornographie wieder auf ist die Darstellung
eines nackten Körpers Pornographie? Ist die Darstellung eines nackten Körpers mitten in einem sexuellen Akt mit einem anderen
nackten Körper ist das Pornographie? So ja und da kommt’s dann wieder auf den gesellschaftlichen Kontext an was glaubt unsere
was hat unsere Gesellschaft für Werte, was hat unsere Gesellschaft für ne Moralvorstellung, was ist Geduldet, was ist tabuisiert?
Ja ist eine Interpretationsfrage. Wir reden ja jetzt eigentlich viel über so die uns so vertraute westliche Welt
(ehem)
Ja vorhin haste ja schon mal kurz Kamasutra erwähnt, wie ist denn das so mit den andern großen Kulturen hast Du da
irgendwelche Einblicke oder ist das im Wesentlichen mit dem westlichen Fortschritt in dem Bereich beschäftigt?
Nja also ich hab mich vor allen Dingen mit dem beschäftigt was westliche Forscher zu dem Thema zu sagen haben
Ja
und das ist vor allen Dingen natürlich das das fokussiert auf diesen ganzen auf der westlichen Welt.
Ja aber ich meine man kennt ja jetzt auch genug Bilder also zumindest mir ist schon das ein oder andere unter gekommen
so aus Japan China und so weiter das sind ja auch alles recht explizite Zeichnungssammlungen zu finden
es ist auf jeden Fall ein Globales Phänomen.
Ich wollt grad sagen also Pornographie begleitet uns schon seit wir seit Menschen existieren und es ist einfach auch
ein ein Ausdruck ein ein Kultureller Ausdruck also Pornographie ist Teil unser unser menschlichen Kultur.
Es gibt es in jeden in jeder Gesellschaft gibt es Pornographie oder gibt es zumindest die Darstellung expliziter sexueller Akte.
So, ob man das Pornographie nennen mag oder nicht Pornographie hat ja hat ja diese Konnotation von Tabu von
wir geilen uns dran auf. Das ist mittlerweile unsere moderne Definition auch von Pornographie es hat was mit Ero... also es hat was
mit mit der mit Arousing also man muss so zu sagen das auf ne bestimmte Art und Weise rezipieren.
Ja aber es ist ja interessant das ausgerechnet das was eigentlich alle schon immer machen ja regelmäßig ich meine diese ganze Welt
Gäbs nicht wenn nicht die ganze Zeit gefickt werden würde und
so das dann ausgerechnet dieser Spaß der damit ja auch verbunden ist, ist das sone Eigenschaft so der der Menschen
ja so und in der Tierwelt hat man immer so den Eindruck es ist so im wesentlichen son reproduktiver Normalzustand der jetzt nicht unbedingt
somit Spaß Begeisterung ist ne wobei hier als ich vor drei Sendungen über das Gehirn gesprochen habe,
meinte er auch so naja der der John so bei den Bonobos zum Beispiel ist irgendwie auch extrem zu bemerken das sie also auch
erhöhte sexuelle Aktivität haben also ich will sagen es ist einfach so es ist einfach so normal und so Standard
und alle alle wolln‘s, alle mögen‘s ja und trotzdem haben wir so ein Mechanismus in unserer Gesellschaft der denn genau
das irgendwie unterdrückt... ist doch vollkommen bekloppt.
Naja das interessante an Pornographie ist ja das Pornographie immer die Tabus einer jeweiligen Gesellschaft aufgreift
und etwas das tabuisiert ist ansprechen damit macht man sich natürlich bei denen die momentan die Deutungshoheit
über was ist Moral, was ist, wie wollen wir gemeinsam leben damit macht man sich halt nicht besonders beliebt.
Wenn man Dinge anspricht von denen die Leute die das definiert haben wenn die gesagt haben das ist jetzt nicht
Teil unserer Gesellschaft so wollen wir nicht mit einander leben und deswegen sind auch in der viktorianischen Pornographie
ist das deswegen auch so also völlig prioritätenlos weil also es gibt nicht dies den sexuellen Akt der jetzt besonders geil wäre
oder so sondern einfach nur die Beschreibung überhaupt von expliziter Sexualität das alleine ist der Akt der die Gesellschaft
in den Moment oder der die die Gesetzgeber, die Kirchen, die moralischen Anstalten das ist das was das so zu sagen
angreift
Ja aber warum also ich meine warum hält sich das so, warum hat sich nicht die Gesellschaft nicht irgendwann mal
damit einfach in Frieden begeben sagt so ja klar es gehört irgendwie dazu wir tun's alle ich meine es vollkommen normal
ja so wie Internet so ist ja auch irgendwie mittlerweile allgemein akzeptiert man darf auch drüber reden so nur
irgendwie so beim beim beim Sex drehen irgendwie alle total durch.
Naja vielleicht ist es dann nicht mehr so spannend?
Du hast da keine Erkenntnisse warum sich jetzt irgendwie dieses moralische ausgerechnet immer daran so abarbeitet?
Naja also ich meine sexu also Sexualität ist ja erst mal was was größtenteils im Raum der Privatsphäre also im im
häuslichen Rahmen sag ich jetzt mal stattfindet und wir hatten ja, erinnerst du dich an diesen Talkshowboom
der 90er Jahre wo dann auf einmal hier ich bin übrigens Mark Fetisch sowieso ich hab das jetzt mal mitgebracht
ich zeig euch das jetzt mal so im Nachmittagsfernsehn, fändest du das irgendwie geil das war doch total furchtbar?
Ich fand jetzt diese ganzen Talkshows schon an sich anstrengend so dass ich den jetzt auch nicht so gefolgt habe
Grad mal ging da ging da so viel über so Fetisch
(hm)
Ja gut das immer so dieses herauszerren der der Minderheit was da an der Stelle war. Also damit so die die
Ach komm jeder hat sowas also deine sexuelle Landkarte...
Nein ich meine ich mein diese Talkshows waren ja generell so gepolt so das so der der der Pöbel dann auch immer noch
irgendwas vorgeführt bekommt was was irgendwie noch absurder und anders ist so zu sagen so hier...
Nja eigentlich nicht wirklich
für euch...
weil wir sind alle absurd und anders das ist ja das interessante also jeder denkt ja von sich irgendwie sein persönlicher Fetisch
ist jetzt irgendwie absurd und anders aber das stimmt überhaupt nicht jeder hat sowas also es gibt der momentane Stand
der der Sexualforschung sagt ja auch wir haben sone sexuelle Landkarte. Diese Landkarte haben wir die ist fertig
bevor wir in die Pubertät kommen das heißt, bevor wir in die Pubertät kommen haben wir diese Landkarte schon obwohl
wir noch nicht sexuell aktiv sind eventuell ja.
Landkarte im Sinne von was ist darauf verzeichnet?
Landkarte... Was ich geil finde, was mich an macht, was ich im was ich im Kopfkino hab wenn ich mir einen runterhole so.
Ja
Das ist die sexuelle Landkarte.
Ok
Und das das ist alles schon vor der Pubertät alles schon fertig ja, und in der Pubertät wenn wir anfangen sexuell aktiv zu werden
dann fangen wir so zu sagen an die Grenzen dieser Landkarte auszuloten für uns selber und natürlich
denkst du dann erst mal "um Gottes Willen ich steh auf sowas das ist um Gott um Gottes Willen ich bin pervers." oder so.
(ehem)
Aber das Denken alle alle denken das ja. Alle halten sich für pervers aber das ist halt nicht so weil es halt irgendwie es gibt da keine Norm.
Bei Sexualität gibt es keine Norm.
Wir sind alle pervers.
Ja also naja wir sind vor allen Dingen alle sexuell aktiv und wir haben nicht alle die gleichen Interessen. Also Vanille Blümchensex
hetronormativer Vanille Blümchensex ist würde ich sagen eher die Ausnahme als die Norm und es gibt wirklich keine Sexuelle Norm
sondern es gibt halt nur Interessengruppen.
Das heißt die mit dem Blümchensex das sind eigentlich Perversen.
Vielleicht also und und ich mein das gesamte Erwachsenleben dreht sich dann eigentlich nur darum die Interessensgruppe
zu finden die man dann auch hat also Leute aus der eigenen Interessensgruppe zu finden.
Ja
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Nee nee
Und Pornographie hilft da also ich ich sehe Pornographie auch so ein bisschen dann...
In wie fern hilft es?
Weil du dir Sachen ankucken kannst wo du denkst "um Gottes Willen, darauf steh ich auch, ich bin gar nicht alleine ich habe da
offensichtlich gibt es da Leute die das auch toll finden was ich toll finde."
Ja
und das kann für jemanden der gerade erst anfängt mit seiner eigenen Sexualität umzugehen kann das augenöffnend sein
sich Pornographie anzukucken wo er sagt er steht darauf und deswegen muss ich auch echt nochmal sagen, Leute die sagen
das das Pornographie Jugendliche in irgendeiner Form pervers macht oder komisch macht die haben einfach noch nicht so wirklich
was... also die haben nicht verstanden worum’s da eigentlich geht oder wie das funktioniert mit der Pornographie.
Weil das geht so nicht.
Ja, wie funktioniert's?
Na es ist halt so wie gesagt also die Landkarte ist fertig das ist so als würdest du nem nem Jugendlichen der sagt von sich
er ist heterosexuell und du zeigst ihm Schwulen Pornos und dann wird der schwul. Das funktioniert ja so nicht ja und deswegen kannst du
auch niemanden in irgendeiner Form Pornographie zeigen wo du sagst da wird jetzt der und der Fetisch wird da jetzt besonders
heraus gehoben und auf einmal fängt dieser Jugendliche oder diese Jugendliche dann an diesen Fetisch toll zu finden.
Das geht so nicht,
Ja
sondern das ist wenn dann schon da und dann sagen sie "mein Gott jetzt habe ich mich endlich erkannt, um Gottes Willen es gibt noch Leute
die so sind wie ich halle Julia"
Ja
und deswegen halte ich Pornographie für ne gute Sache.
Ja das ist mir auch aufgefallen wenn man mal in son Sexshop reinlatscht so und sich mal dieses ganze Produktpottfolio mal nen
bisschen näher anschaut also mein (...) ich hab mal ne weile damit beschäftigt weil ich ja auch mal in diesem Business
mal kurz gearbeitet habe und
Ich erinnre mich.
dachte so jetzt muss jetzt musste dir das auch mal irgendwie genau anschauen so und was mir dann irgendwie sehr schnell klar wurde
ist so wow also diese ganze Pornokino, Porno also gar nicht mehr nur so Porno aber auch so dieses ganze Sex- Business
so dass das bindet auch irgendwie ne Menge Energie ja. Also gäbe es dieses breite Angebot nicht also würdest es jetzt so morgen
aufen Knopf drücken und alle Sexshops würden auf einmal verschwinden ja, also das gesamte Pornoangebot an sich wäre weg
ja also das ganze Internet wäre frei, youporn würde es nicht mehr geben, es gäbe keine Pornofilme mehr, keine Pornoliteratur,
nicht irgendwie, könntest keine Dildos kaufen etc. pp all dieser ganze Kram es wäre weg. Ich glaub dann könnte man so wirklich
so auf die Uhr schauen und irgendwie spätestens nach 48 Stunden hast du einfach brennende Autos in den Straßen
und das ist immer son bisschen so mein Eindruck, das einfach dadurch auch sehr viel abgefedert wird was sich ansonsten
so ich meine sind wir wieder bei diesen bei den Griechen ja und diesen dem Krieg ja die dann so zu sagen sogar aufgehört haben
Krieg zu führen damit sie irgendwie das noch bekommen ja, wäre die Position andersrum gewesen mit so wenn ihr jetzt hier
nicht in den Krieg zieht gib’s kein Sex mehr dann wär’s bestimmt auch in die andere Richtung gelaufen.
Das kann sein, also ich bin das ist finde ich ne schwierige schwierige Sache weil man dann son bisschen den Zusammenhang
stellt 1. zwischen Pornographie was ja quasi die Abbildung sexueller Akte auf ne normierte Art und Weise ist
und das in Verbindung gestellt mit tatsächlichen Akten also wenn du von einer anderen Richtung her kommst das ist
das ist auch ne Richtung das ist nen sehr sehr starkes Augment die sagen dann zum Beispiel "ja Pornographie verführt
zu übergriffigen sexuellen Akten" also es gibt es gibt ne Bewegung die sagt Pornos führen dazu das Vergewaltiger vergewaltigen
zum Beispiel.
(ehem)
Und ich finde man muss das son bisschen trennen also Pornographie ist sehr sehr stark kodiert und Pornographie hat ja mit Sexualität
erst mal nicht zu tun also Sex und Pornos das gehört nicht zusammen und das finde ich ist auch was was man das sollte man
in Schulen lehren ja man sollte so zu sagen irgendwie mit den mit den ganzen 17 18 Jährigen Oberschülern mal Pornos kucken
und dann sagen also das da und das was ihr da im Bett das hat das hat nicht viel mit einander zu tun weil Pornographie muss
kodiert sein dafür, weil wir Pornographie nur mit den Augen wahrnehmen also jetzt visuelle Pornographie, Pornofilme
Ja
schauen wir. Und unsere Augen sind unserer kältester Sinn. Sex funktioniert ja auf ganz anderen Ebenen... das ist sehr haptisch,
sehr olfaktorisch also das ist ja ne ganz, da werden ja ganz andere Sinne angesprochen
Ja
und damit Pornographie funktioniert muss das als Pornographie erkennbar sein und deswegen müssen bestimmte Dinge drin vorkommen.
Also unsere Gesellschaft hat ein ein ganz starken Kodex also ein ein Code ein visuellen Code der auf der der bei
Pornographie funktioniert. Ich meine wenn du mal Pornos kuckst so aus den aus den 90ern bis jetzt so 2000sener
die jetzt für für ein Video-Publikum gemacht wurden sind oder ein DVD-Publikum das ist das fängt halt mit bestimmten
Praktiken an du hast halt irgendwie erst den Blowjob dann ist irgendwie vaginaler Sex und dann ist analer Sex also ich rede jetzt
über heterosexuellen Porno
Ja
und am Ende ist dann irgendwie noch vielleicht nen Gang bang oder so also das sind alles ganz das die Reihenfolge muss
eingehalten werden es fängt nicht mit dem Gang bang an sondern das steigert sich
Ja
und das ist auch die Art und Weise wie das gemacht wird und wer da wo welche Stellungen hat das ist sehr sehr stark
für eben genau dieses visuelle Wahrnehmen kodiert und natürlich auch die Rezeptionsweise also das ist das sind ja Teilweise
20 minütige Szenen wenn du im Kino kucken musst, da stirbst du also das ist tatsächlich für die für die remote fürs Vorspulen gemacht.
Ja
und
Das man weiß wo man hin spulen muss je nach dem was man grad so meint so ja Ok.
Was man gerade sehen will genau und ich mein ich hab mal ich hab mal nen Porno der für dieses DVD-Publikum gemacht ist im
Kino gesehen, ich bin fast gestorben vor Langeweile
es war so furchtbar und also dieses ja also das war einfach so völlig unspektakuläres gerammel 20 Minuten lang
und das war einfach extrem langweilig das heißt also das das sind Filme die für'n ganz bestimmte Art der Rezeption auch
gemacht wurden sind und das übersetzt sich natürlich nicht ins Schlafzimmer oder auf den Küchentisch oder wo auch immer
du Sex hast aber du kannst jetzt nicht also das das ne das ist tatsächlich fürs kucken gemacht.
Ja
Und nicht fürs nachmachen.
Filme, jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip noch son bisschen so im viktorianischen Zeitalter stecken geblieben, ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie wie wie schnell wir da jetzt vorspulen sollten um noch mal um nicht zu viele relevante Schritte da noch zu übergehen
aber irgendwann hat sich das ja dann hat sich die Technik geändert und damit hat sich ja auch der Porno geändert.
Genau naja also zuerst kam ja vor allen Dingen erst mal die Fotographie, wo man dann tatsächlich nackte Körper auch
fotographisch darstellen konnte.
(hmm)
Es gab dann Aktfotos, natürlich nur zu Zwecken der der Künstler also die Künstler durften dann tatsächlich Aktfotos
auch sich anfertigen lassen zu Studienzwecken.
Ja
Das sah dann auch teilweise waren das dann auch Bewegungsstudien zum Beispiel Edward Muybridge den viele kennen
von seine Pferdefotos. Der hat Pferde fotografiert wie sie mit einer bestimmten Technik so das man sehen konnte wie sich
Pferde tatsächlich bewegen. Der hat eine nicht so ganz bekannte Bewegungsstudie auch von Frauen gemacht
(ehem)
und auch von nackten Männer nackte Körper die sich bewegen. Genau also diese Fotos wurden dann auch sehr schnell
sehr explizit und wurden dann auch zum explizierten Zwecke der Aufgeilung verteilt.
Ja
Auch wieder natürlich voraus also größtenteils an Männer und von den Fotos ging’s dann halt relativ flott zum Film.
(hmm)
Natürlich erste Stummfilme und in Europa hat sich davon vor allen Dingen Österreich sehr hervor getan die erste
Filmproduktionsfirma die in Öste... also die sich in Wien angesiedelt hat, die hieß Saturnfilm und Saturnfilm hat eigentlich nur
Pornographische Kurzfilme gemacht und diese Filme...
Das war die erste Filmproduktionsfirma in Österreich oder...?
In Europa
In Europa!
die also die sich die sich also...
Also die erste die sich darum gekümmert hat oder die erste die es überhaupt gab?
es war eine der ersten die es überhaupt gab also
(hah)
das war ja...
Also gleich vom Start weg irgendwie Film gleich Porno zack
Gleich vom Start weg gleich Pornos genau. Also das war auch relativ der erste der erste Film der als pornographisch eingestuft
war und so benutzt wurde ist noch aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Also das ist so zu sagen ganz am Anfang das ist Salomes Tanz, Salome zeigt
nicht mehr sehr viel als Wade aber Wade war damals schon "eieiei" also...
Ja
So und Salome
Aber kein Rock drüber ne
Nee genau sie zeigt ihr Wade und das und das funktionierte ja damals so diese Filme wurden nicht verliehen oder in Kinos
gezeigt, das gab es damals noch nicht es gab kein Verleihsystem sondern wie das funktionierte war es gab fahrende Händler
die mit Zirkussen und Warieteshows durch die Lande fuhren und die auch in einem kleinen Koffer in der Ecke ihrer Wage
hatten sie dann auch sone Kiste von von Pornofilmen. Das waren Filmrollen eine Rolle war ungefair 10 Minuten Film das waren
also meistens so diese diese sogenannten one reeler es war ein Rolle
(hmm)
manchmal auch zwei und die haben sie dann vorgeführt entweder in den Varieteshows für spezielle Erwachsenenvorstellungen
da kam dann Herren. Aber vor allen Dingen in den schon vorher erwähnten Herrenclubs. Das heißt sie sind von Ort zu Ort gezogen
durch die Herrenclubs und haben diese Filme vorgeführt. Nun wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt da sitzen jetzt irgendwie so naja 50 bis 70
Herren in einem Raum gemeinsam und kucken sich erotische Filme an, möglichst also also ja die auch vielleicht den einen
oder anderen dann
In Wallung bringen
In Wallung bringen genau, so und jetzt hat man da diese diese erotische Spannung die man aber in dem Moment nicht ausleben
kann
Ja also ich hab mich das ehrlich gesagt auch bei Pornokinos immer schon son bisschen gefragt ja
Nja pass auf pass auf da gib’s ein ein total tollen Trick unzwar diese Pornofilme waren lustig, die hatten also du kennst den Begriff
Comic Relief der ist wörtlich zu nehmen. Unzwar waren diese diese diese gab’s diese frühen Vignetten diese Kurzfilme waren
tatsächlich witzig also da geht’s immer darum, der Mann ist sowieso immer gearschte also der hat irgendwie immer
das Nachsehen und die Frauen sind geben den Ton an und es gibt es gibt es gibt Filme da hypnotisieren die
Prostituierte ihren Kunden und lassen den so als Huhn durch die Gegend nehmen ihm auch noch irgendwie die Hand also das Geld
weg und so und er und lassen ihn in den Glauben er hat jetzt tollen Sex gehabt und so und das ist also das ist das ist en sehr
kruder Humor aber das ist der Humor der der frühen Stummfilme.
(ehem)
Und die Frauen haben grundsätzlich immer die Hosen an also es ist so dass die Frauen entscheiden was sie wollen,
wann sie wollen, mit wem sie wollen und wenn sie nicht wollen dann muss der Mann mit der Ziege weil sie haben dann halt nee gesagt.
Also sehr sehr emanzipatorisch und das liegt halt daran das das in der Gesellschaft der Zeit war das halt ganz anders ne.
Das war also man muss sich vorstellen das war immer noch eine Zeit wo Frauen kein kein sexuelles Verlangen haben dürfen,
es war es war eine Zeit wo Sex für Frauen zur Reproduktion war und man auch gesagt hat "ja die haben halt kein
Interesse dran" und so und
Es gibt auch kein weiblichen Orgasmus
Nee nee genau das das kam alles später das waren so die 10er 20er Jahre und in diesen ganz ganz frühen Stummfilmen also
so bis bis 1915 1920 waren das tatsächlich echt also das war ein Tabu und deswegen sind diese Film so weil es in der Gesellschaft
ein Tabu war deswegen hat man dieses Tabu gezeckt, das war erotisch.
(hm)
Also das war pornographisch und dann kam ja erst irgendwie der Sieges
Und es war in gewisser Hinsicht auch wieder wirklich back to the rules so Geschichten von Prostituierten.
Naja es waren Prostituierte in diesen Filmen weil man die Bezahlen konnte und die haben das dann gemacht. Also
Pornostars insofern gab’s es nicht. Das gab es dann eher bei den Männern also die ganz frühen Filme, die Männer
waren eher so aus den gehobenen Schichten wie gesagt, der gelangweilte Adel Frauen waren Prostituierte. Weil das
die einzigen verfügbaren Frauen waren die sich nackt...
Klar mein ich,
es sind wieder also es ist wieder Pornographie im ursprünglichen Wortsinne so hier Geschichten von Prostituierten.
gezeigt haben
Geschichten von und über Prostituierten genau.
Naja und dann gab’s ja so diesen diesen Siegeszug des Vibrators. Der son bisschen auch in der Gesellschaft auch was verändert hat.
Den kennste oder?
Den Vibrator als solchen hab ich schon mal gesehen
Haste das schon mal gehört Tim? Das ist ja wunderbar. Es gibt ja immer noch genügend Jungs die der Meinung sind
sie müssen sich mit phallischen Sexspielzeug nicht auseinander setzen was immer sehr schade ist. Aber jedenfalls
gab’s es ja dann, es gab ja dann Freud und die Hysterie kranken und das war ja damals so eine son bisschen sone Modediagnose
das Frauen waren hysterisch oder Hysterie krank und da gab es eine Behandlung dafür und diese Behandlung war
(so zu) das das hieß Manual Therapie und es war, das muss man sich so vorstellen das die Ärzte tatsächlich den Frauen
manuell Befriedigung verschafft haben um sie von dieser Hysterie zu heilen.
Das wurde auch schon von Kadda angesprochen als wir uns im Kontext von Feminismus darüber unterhalten haben
was mir in dem Moment nicht bewusst war und dann erst im Nachgang auf viel ist ja das das Wort "Hysterie"
tatsächlich wiederum vom altgriechischen Hystera kommt und das ist halt die Gebärmutter also so zu sagen...
Es war eine Krankheit der Gebärmutter ja weil nur Frauen wurden befallen und
Also wenn man hysterisch ist ist man so zu sagen, hat man ein Problem mit seiner Gebärmutter das ist das was eigentlich
dahinter steht.
Es war zumindest damals die gängige Vorstellung dieser dieser Krankheit
Völlig absurd ja und denn die Manual Therapie sollte dann eben für Entspannung sorgen?
Genau und damit das so zu sagen die Ärzte deren auch irgendwann die Hände müde wurden die haben sich dann
technische Unterstützung geholt, das man das auch so zu sagen zu Hause anwenden konnte und das (wurde) das gab’s dann auf Rezept
das hat man sich dann irgendwie holen können. Und dann hatte man also eine riesen Maschine zu Hause, ich möchte auch gar nicht
wissen also das das war bestimmt eher gruselig aber man hatte dann eine Maschine mit der man sich zu Hause selber manuell
Therapieren konnte.
Und das ganze und irgendwann gab’s das dann...
Immerhin auf Rezept.
ja genau und irgendwann gab’s das dann als Massagestab im Sells Katalog und von da also also ganz beworben so hier Massagestab
für Frauen und so und keiner hat sich da irgendwas bei gedacht ja und... naja das war so der Siegeszug des Vibrators.
Ja...
Da fing dann auch an die Pornographie anders zu werden. Also je selbstbewusster und emanzipierter die Frauen in der Gesellschaft wurden
desto unterwürfiger wurden sie dann in der Pornographie.
Und wenn wir jetzt von Pornographie reden ,reden wir schon primär von wirklich von Filmen?
Der Film hat die Literatur ziemlich gründlich verdrängt ja. Also es war natürlich erst der Film mittlerweile ist es ja das Internet
was dann wieder ein ganz andere Sehgewohnheit jetzt gerade hervor ruft. Also das wird auch in Zukunft also wir sind gerade in der Mitte
einer sehr sehr spannenden Entwicklung und eines sehr spannenden Parasikmen wechsels, weg vom Film hin zum Internet
und wenn ich Internet sage meine ich natürlich auch jeder noch so absurde Fetisch hat eine eine Interessensgemeinde
und das ist eine eine ganz spannende also dieses Selbstbewusstsein was die die Pornographie auch dadurch erlangt
das ist ein ganz spannende Geschichte.
Bleiben wir erst noch mal kurz beim beim Film also Stummfilmzeit wurde dann irgendwann ja auch überwunden.
Na das hat aber lange gedauert...
Ja
weil die Pornographie war also der der erste Tonfilm war ja Ende der 20er so um 1930 gab’s dann halt die ersten
Tonfilme. Pornographie war bis in die 50er stumm. Weil das also hing technisch einfach hinterher und wurde dann erst
erst so 40er 50er gab’s die ersten Tonfilme.
hmhm
Pornographischen Tonfilme genau und das, man sagt ja immer Pornographie ist sone son son Technologietreiber also beim Film
ist das definitiv nicht so gewesen zumindest am Anfang nicht.
Ja gut aber ich meine zumindest waren sie ja gleich von Anfang an da. Ich meine so ganz ohne Antrieb wird’s nicht gewesen sein.
Ich meine wenn wenn wenn Bedarf...
Ja
für Film auch dadurch geschaffen wird das Leute damit Pornos machen wollen denn ist es ja schon ein Technologietreiber.
Es wieder aber es wieder auch son Fall der Rezeptionssituation du hast halt immer noch nicht diesen diesen diesen
Kinogänger sondern dieses private zeigen im Herrenclub und der Herrenclub hatte halt vielleicht dann auch diese technische Ausstattung
nicht wobei es dann ja auch so langsam in eine in eine breitere gesellschaftliche Richtung ging also wir haben dann
in den in den 60er haben die ersten Versuche erotisches Material auch in Kinos zu kriegen auch für ein Kinopublikum
tatsächlich rezipierbar zu machen. So so raus aus diesem Hinterzimmer und rein in die Populärkultur und das gibt dieses
dieses Genre nannte sich Sexploitationfilm.
hmhm
Das war so ein ein ein Untergenre dieser Exploitationfilme und Exploitationfilme waren reißerische Filme die möglichst
sensations geil versprochen haben und nicht immer delivert haben also das war dann zum Beispiel irgendwie das diese
Monsterfilme und diese also die die haben halt Sex, Drugs, Rock'N'Roll versprochen. Die Poster waren sehr reißerisch,
delivert haben sie nicht immer.
hmhm
Und Sexploitation war dann so zu sagen ein ähnlichen Prinzip aber halt mit sexuellen Anspielungen. Also es wurde dann
es wurde dann zum Beispiel versprochen auf einem Poster "sehen sie jetzt dieses und jenes und Skandal und so weiter"
und dann hast du halt (setzt) haste dich da reingesetzt und dann hast halt ne Geburt gesehen. Also so richtig ungeschönt
eine Geburt.
Und also das das war natürlich überhaupt nicht jetzt anregend sondern es war es war was was du vorher nicht gesehen hattest
war tabuisiert natürlich
Ja
aber es war nicht diese Art und Weise von Sexskandal die auf den Postern beworben wurde.
Also sind auch viele echt dramatisiert wieder raus gegangen weil sie sich was anderes erwartet haben aber natürlich gebildeter
weil sie dann wussten "aha so funktioniert das also mit der Geburt." ne
Ist auch schon mal eine Information
Genau, also es gab zwei zwei Könige der Sexploitation sag ich mal, das eine war Russ Meyer den auch viele denk ich mal kennen,
der war der hat halt Filme gedreht die nicht explizit wurde. Also wenn du ich weiß nicht hast du von dem mal was gesehen?
Ich hab mal, ja in ein oder zwei hab ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das komplett gegeben habe aber ich hab so...
Genau also den...
Immer sehr sehr großbusige Frauen auf jeden Fall
Ja das war so sein Ding.
Das war so sein Fetisch
Ja... also der bekannteste Film von ihm ist Faster, Pussycat! Kill! Kill!
hmhm
Und der ist so bekannt in der Tat das Tarantino hat einen Film gemacht der hieß glaub ich irgendwas mit
Death, Death Car, Death Race die letzte Szene aus Tarantinos Film ist tatsächlich ein synonym mit einer mit einer Szene
aus Faster, Pussycat! Kill! Kill! also Ross Meyer ist in ist tatsächlich sehr in der Populärkultur auch verankert.
hmm
Und der hat diese Filme gemacht die sehr brutal waren
Du meinst Death Proof
Death Proof genau
Ja
Death Proof
Hab ich leider noch nicht gesehen.
Ja also ich kann ich kann da schon was spoilern die letzte Szene und so
Ok verstehe
Und
Achso nee doch den kenn ich Death Proof alles klar das ist der Typ mit Auto
Genau genau und der dann nachher
da rum fährt ahja genau doch den hab ich gesehen
Und Russ Meyer war der King der Raffis, also seine Frauen waren immer sehr brutal, sehr dominant, sehr großbusig
hmm
und dann gab’s es noch Doris Wishman, Doris Wishman ist geheime Königin so der der Pornographie der dieser Zeit so
50er bis 70er Jahre die hat glaub ich über 10nn Filme gemacht und kein Mensch kennt die und das ist total schaden.
Weil die hat angefangen mit nude cutes, nude cutes sind so Filme aus FKK-Kolonien und sie hat son Film gemacht der heißt
Nude to the Moon und da da gehen halt so ja Astronauten fahren auf den Mond und...
Nude on the Moon heist de.
Nude on the Moon genau und der ist von 69 oder so und
61 sogar wow
Ja
Wahnsinn und das ist also ganz immer ganz knapp an der Zensur vorbei ne weil die Frauen barbusig ja alles drunter
durfte man nicht zeigen und
Ja
und auf dem Mond treffen sie jedenfalls eine Kolonie von Mondgöttinnen und Geistern und sie sind alle irgendwie nackt und die Astronauten
irgendwann dann auch aber es passiert halt nichts also es darf auch durfte nicht passieren. Das wär nicht durch die durch die Zensur gegangen
und das ja also sie irgendwie alle alle nackt und so und das war halt so da kam Doris Wishman her die hat dann auch später
Das ist dieser Humor ist so zu sagen dann auch immer noch dabei?
Musste ganz wichtig
Ist immer noch alles so, also musste weil ist jetzt sonst die Zensur nicht gemacht hätte oder weil sich es sonst keiner angeschaut hätte oder?
Das hätte sich sonst keiner geschaut weil du musst dir überlegen das war ein Kino und du bist dahin gegangen und die Zeit
60er 70er das war so die Zeit wo auch Frauen auch mal ins Kino gingen um sich solche Filme anzusehen und du sitzt jedenfalls im
Kino mit Leuten ja und dann siehst du sowas und das erregt dich vielleicht oder auch nicht aber vielleicht erregt es dich und dann sitzt du da
und bist erregt
in einer öffentlichen Situation oder so, semie öffentlich und was machste jetzt damit und deswegen auch. Comic Relief war unglaublich
wichtig weil wenn es nicht lustig gewesen wäre, ich mein was macht man dann mit seiner Erregung ja
Ja
die trägt man dann auf die Straße wieder raus
Verstehe
und irgendwo muss das hin
gut
und dann haste halt gelacht und dann war wieder ok. Und diese Filme also das ist ja auch Sexploitation und danach in den 70er
das goldene Zeitalter der Pornographie das sind auch die schönsten Filme es sind echt die lustigsten, amüsantesten Filme die auch
also so auch absurde narrative Bögen haben.
Die 70er Jahre sind das golden Zeitalter der Pornographie?
Ja aber!
Weil?
Weil sie in Kinos gezeigt wurde, weil das das erste also sie hatten Budget
Ja
Ja sie haben sich auch echt Gedanken gemacht, das war das Zeitalter wo sie gesagt haben jetzt sind wir eine eine befreite Gesellschaft,
jetzt können wir Pornographie in unsere Gesellschaft tatsächlich als als Teil unserer Gesellschaft ganz öffentlich und ohne
Scham einbinden.
So zu sagen als Begleitmaßnahme der sexuellen Revolution.
Genau also 1969 wurde Pornographie son bisschen gesellschaftsfähig da gab es auch die erste Sex Messe in Dänemark.
Pornographie wurde tatsächlich legal. Also 69 70 war waren die Jahre in der Pornographie legal wurde.
Wo?
Weltweit! Also in Amerika, in Deutschland, in Europa
hmhm
Es gab diese es gab diese Sex Messe und es gab dann das war das Zeitalter der Schwedenpornos das ist son Begriff
weil eben genau auch diese skandinavischen Länder waren so die ersten die gesagt "wir legalisieren jetzt Pornographie"
hmhm
und deswegen waren waren die 70er Jahre auch so dieses "Ja! jetzt sind nicht mehr..." also ne der Hays Code hat dann aufgehört.
der Hays Code war eine Zensurmaßnahme der Studios die sich auferlegt haben gewisse Dinge nicht zu zeigen.
Und da ging’s also Hays Code war ja eigentlich für Hollywood, also wer wer Pornographie machen konnte das wurde auch immer
Pornographie produziert und so das war aber im illegalen. Aber Hollywood Filme zum Beispiel du kennst diese Doris Day Filme
Ja
Und hast dich vielleicht gefragt die sind verheiraten und schlafen in zwei unterschiedlichen Betten warum? Wegen dem Hays Code.
Ahh
Man durfte also ein ein Film Kuss durfte nicht länger als 3 Sekunden dauern und es gab da ein ein es war ein offiziell
ne Selbstverpflichtung aber inoffiziell hast du halt keine Freigabe gekriegt wenn du dich nicht dran gehalten hast.
hmhm
Und das der der das waren so nja 30er bis bis 60er 70er waren das so war so die Hochzeit des Hays Code.
Das heißt Filme aus der Zeit sind sehr sehr zahm und züchtig.
Ja
Und in den 60ern mit der Sexploitation da ging das so in der Underground Culture
los und in den 70ern haben sie dann gedacht "ja! das wird jetzt also irgendwann wird es nur noch Filme geben wo es und
so richtig zur Sache geht und es ist super und alle kucken sich das an und" da sind auch echt richtig das erste mal Massen
in die Kinos geströmt also vor allen Dingen nicht nur Männer aus den oberen Schichten sondern alle ja also so.
Was ist da jetzt so exemplarisch also was würdest du da so hervor heben?
Naja der Film aus der Zeit der die meisten kontroversen natürlich auch gespornt hat war Deep Throat.
hmhm
Und Deep Throat war ein Kinophänomen und auch Deep Throat wurde verboten, wurde dann auch zensiert aus den Kinos
aber das war wirklich der Film wo auch, den auch den auch richtig viele Leute gesehen haben und wo die Leute auch ins Kino
gegangen sind um um zu sagen "Ja ich find jetzt das vielleicht nicht so interessant aber ich gehe für mein Recht auf das ich das sehen darf,
ich bin erwachsen, ich bin mündig, ich habe ein Recht das zu sehen deswegen gehe ich da hin." also das das war eine politische Kontroverse
diese Filme.
Und was geht da so in dem Film?
Naja der ist nicht so spannend also ich find den nicht so spannend es ist halt in dem Film geht’s darum das eine Frau
jetzt das Gefühl hat sie kann kein Orgasmus bekommen auf auf auf klitorale Art und Weise oder bzw. kein vaginalen Orgasmus
und geht dann zum Arzt und der Arzt stellt fest, naja das ist ja auch kein Wunder weil du hast deine Klitoris in deinem Hals
in deinem Rachen
und deswegen kannst du nur so
Nur oral befriedigt werden
ne na nicht oral sondern sie muss so zu sagen also in ihrem Rachen ist ihre Klitoris und sie erlangt Befriedigung
dadurch das sie Blowjobs gibt und halt die Technik Deep Throat also einen einen erigierten Penis bis zum Anschlag und bis hinter
den Würgereflex so zu sagen kommt aus diesem Film.
hm
Ne also das die Technik so heißt wurde mit diesem Film dann zementiert.
Verstehe wow
Ansonsten ist der Film jetzt kein, der ist auch sehr witzig also der der hat auch durchaus Humor.
hmhm
Aber der ist jetzt nicht einer meiner Lieblingsfilme aus der Zeit sondern es gibt ein paar die die ich lieber zitiere...
Aber es wird jetzt auch nicht alles angedeutet sondern da wird’s dann auch gemacht?
Das ist ein Porno ja ja.
Ok ja gut ich frag ja nur weiß der Geier
Nee nee also das ist an andeuten ist da nicht mehr sondern das ist dann
Ok alles klar da geht’s richtig ab aber das war so richtig im Kino aber dann halt nur ab 18 oder ja ja?
Ja ja ah natürlich also
Ja weiß ich?
Klar aber Erwachsene mündige Menschen hatten halt das also und vor allen Dingen
Aber der war dann Gott sein dank auch noch ein bisschen lustig so dass sie sich dann alle noch...
Ja man konnte also man konnte als Pärchen da auch rein gehen ohne sich hinterher beschämt anzukucken und zu sagen "um Gottes Willen".
Hach wow
Ja also der Film den ich aus der Zeit immer am liebsten zitiere ist Flesh Gordon.
Ja
Also Flesh mit "e" natürlich
Weil der auch son bisschen das Genre des des Spofs begründet also das...
Der sich so zu sagen an im andern Film kopiert so zu sagen
und eine Pornovariante draus macht oder was?
Nun ja
Phänomene der Popkultur pornographisch persifliert das ist Spofs und Flesh Gordon ist einer der ersten der so richtig weit
bekannt war und der ist super, der ist fantastisch also alles in diesem Film also die Bühnenbilder sind toll also alles in diesem Film
ist phallisch also so die die Grotten und die das die Rakete mit der sie fliegen ist ein riesiger goldener Phallus und es ist mit soviel
Liebe zum Detail, es ist wirklich wirklich also ganz fantastisch und sie gehen dann auf den auf den Planeten Porno und dann hat der
da son Sexstrahl dieser Emperor Wang der und und wenn dieser Sexstrahl auf die Erde trifft dann müssen alle Leute sich sofort die Kleider
vom Leib reißen und und Sex haben und ich meine der Film der ist gar nicht so explizit also da da wird nicht - da wird viel zu wenig
gevögelt für das, was wir jetzt so als Pornographie verstehen sondern er hat richtig ne Handlung. Also ich mein klar da geht’s denn
also die die müssen sich unter jedem Prätext dann auch die die Klamotten vom Leib reißen und Sex haben aber der ist richtig
witzig und er ist auch richtig gut also den kann man auch auf Partys spielen das ist kein Problem so.
Ist nen super Film kann jeden nur empfehlen versprochen.
Ok aber er hat auch immer noch viel dieses Humorelement sozusagen?
Ja genau das also der ist halt tatsächlich
Geht das das ganze goldene Zeitalter des Pornos so weiter?
Ja also das das liegt halt wie gesagt an dieser Rezeptionssituation. Das hört dann erst auf in den 80er Jahren. Das hört dann
relativ abrupt auf und da ist zum einen die geänderte Rezeptionssituation schuld, also die Leute gehen dem gehen weiniger in Kinos,
jetzt haben wir irgendwie Videorekorder
Genau da kam ja so VHS auf...
Ja die ersten Verleihe auch die tatsächlich Filme verliehen haben
hmhm
Pornofilme die direkt für Video auch produziert wurden und so und dann ist der Humor in dem Moment nicht mehr so irre wichtig
weil wenn du alleine sitzt vor deinem vor deinem also vor deinem Fernseher zu Hause und dir das ankuckst dann ist das nicht mehr
wichtig das du diesen Comic Relief hast das du da drüber lachen musst weil ich meine da sitzt du eh alleine und das merkt keiner
du kannst dir ein runterholen.
Das heißt das war so zu sagen der Tag an dem der Humor aus dem Porno verschwand.
Ja son bisschen eher so die Dekade aber ja.
Ja na gut ist sicherlich sone Phase gewesen aber für jeden war’s dann irgendwann mal der Tag gekommen wo so zu sagen
Humorfreie Pornos liefen zu Hause.
Ja und also es ist also und es gibt tatsächlich auch son Film an dem man das so festmachen kann das ist dieser Film heißt
Café Flesh, der ist aus den frühen 80ern und dieser Film beschäftigt sich inhaltlich in der Tat also man muss sich das vorstellen
wir haben irgendwie kalter Krieg und Atombombenscare und dieser Film beschäftigt sich mit distopischen Gesellschaft
in der es einen es gab einen es gab ein Krieg und es war es ist so zu sagen Endzeit und die Leute die überlebt haben sind
zu einem größten Teil in irgendeiner Form verstrahlt und können keine keinen Orgasmus mehr erlangen und keine sexuellen
Gefühle mehr also kein keine sexuellen Empfindungen mehr erreichen und das sind 99% der Leute.
hmhm
Und dann gibt es 1% die können das noch.
Ja
Und diese 1% sind dann so zu sagen dazu verpflichtet in ja in in Art Varieteshows oder in so sexuell motivierten Shows
aufzutreten die auch total bizarr sind um diese 99% daran zu erinnern was sie verloren haben und das ist ein Film der ist
extrem deprimierend also wahnsinnig deprimierend und total absurd also von der von der Visualität her.
Warum sollen sie daran erinnert werden? Ist doch voll voll depri.
Ja das ist total depri also du siehst dann auch die Gesichter dieser Leute und die sind alle ganz weiß Geschminkt mit riesigen Augenringen
und du denkst irgendwie, die sind kurz davor jetzt irgendwie zu sterben also ganz ganz unglückliche Menschen.
Ja aber warum geben die sich das also versteh ich nicht?
Ja das ist in dieser in dieser Film in dieser Filmwelt, sie wollen halt nochmal dran erinnert werden an die glücklichen Tage.
Wie schön das war.
Und das muss man auch dazu sagen dieser Film kommt zu einer Zeit wo
Also sie erinnern sich so zu sagen schon so dass es ihnen mal so ging
Ja ja und muss halt auch mal man auch dazu sagen das dieser Film in einer politischen Situation des kalten Krieges und und dem
der möglichen Endzeit kommt sondern es markiert halt auch son bisschen das Ende der unbeschwerten Sexualität
also die 80zieger sind ja auch das AIDS-Zeitalter
Ja
und das heißt also das dieses dieses unbeschwerte also das ist für auch in der Pornographie so zu sagen
dann erst mal zu Ende und und ein Umgang ein anderer Umgang Sexualität ein vernünftigerer oder ein mäßiger
Ja verstehe das heißt das Atomkiregsszenario könnte man auch so zu sagen als als Synonym für dieses AIDS-Desaster
somit irgendwie Sex verboten und so ich meine das war ja echt das war echt nen harter Schlag ne auch so für die Jugend
ja weil vorher war noch irgendwie Hippie und wir haben uns alle lieb
Freie Liebe
und freie Liebe und hier und Kommune 1 und den ganzen Tag wälzen wir die Körper aufeinander und wer irgendwie
zweimal mit der gleichen pennt gehört schon zum Establishment und so und dann auf einmal so Bremse (quietsch) so ach ja übrigens jetzt
irgendwie AIDS ficken verboten.
Jaja ich mein das man auch Spaß haben kann und man benutzt halt dann einfach mal irgendwie die nötigen Vorkehrungen.
Ja klar aber das war ja trotzdem war auf einmal diese diese Bremse war ja auch generell da
es war jetzt es war jetzt
so dass das Lustvolle auf einmal mit Gefahr verbunden war so und ich meine es war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht klar ob jetzt irgendwie
Kondom hilft oder so ja also... man wusste ja nichts die die Krankheit brach auf einmal aus
hm
es war relativ schnell klar dass es irgendwie damit zusammenhing ja aber du wusstest jetzt ja nicht ob schon irgendwie auch nur so
die Annäherung in irgendeiner Form dann zu einer Übertragung geführt hat und gab alle möglichen Theorien ja bis hin zu
Verschwörungstheorien das das jetzt mal wieder in irgendwelchen Geheimlabors der CIA ausgeheckt wurde und so weiter...
Naja und es war halt auch keine kulturelle Praxis tatsächlich irgendwie Safer Sex war natürlich noch kein, also Kondome
gib’s ja schon Ewigkeiten aber...
War eher die Ausnahme genau und auf einmal wurde es zwang.
Bzw. es wurde...nja es war es war halt nicht die kulturelle Praxis sondern du hast halt früher Kondome vor allen Dingen dazu benutzt
um Frauen nicht zu schwängern also diese Scharfhautkondome und so also das das waren tatsächlich Verhütungs..(em em)
verhindernde also verhütende Maßnahmen und das Kondome allgemein ein ein sinnvoller Teil jedweder
Hygenefaktor haben ja
Hygiene ja oder auch son son ja also Safer Sex Bestandteil sind das hat sich ja in der kulturell also das sind ja erst...
haja keine Ahnung paar Jahrzehnte mehr ist das ja nicht ne?
hmm
so...
Das kam ja im Prinzip auch erst so mit Beate Use wirklich in Wallung.
Ja Institut für Ehehygiene und so...
Genau
hm
Da hat sich einiges bewegt.
Jaha... allerdings so und Beate Use hat ja auch immer dafür gekämpft auch tatsächlich sexuelle Erfüllung
dann auch für Frauen attraktiver zu machen also letztens hatten sie ja auch Sexshops für Frauen und so diese Geschichten.
Ich mein ist natürlich nen bisschen das Bemühen aus einem vergangen Jahrhundert weil seit wir das Internet haben
brauchen wir nicht mehr Sexshops für Frauen sondern einfach nur Internetsexshops für jeden so...
von daher aber die Bemühung fand ich ganz nett.
Wie ist denn das so ich meine das kam ja auch im Podcast zum Feminismus natürlich auch zur Sprache grad in den 70er Jahren
so da wurde ja auch Pornographie als Begriff schnell zum Kampfbegriff
ehem
und wurde dann von der feministischen Bewegung zumindest Teilen davon dann auch gleich gesetzt mit Gewalt gegen Frauen
der Porno war dann eben auch son Feindbild mit unter der eben ja so zu sagen als gegen die Frau gewendet
war und jetzt haben wir das natürlich schon bei der Betrachtung der ganzen Geschichte war es klar das war im wesentlichen
sone Sache der Herren(ähäh)clubs und der Eilten und die Frauen war da irgendwie ausgeschlossen aber das ändert sich ja auch
oder hat sich geändert es gibt ja auch so Trends feministische Pornos oder Pornos für Frauen von Frauen
wie ist das zu bewerten diese was für eine Bewegung gab’s denn dann?
Geschichtlich es gab ja es gab ja die Propornfemins und die Internpornfeminis gib’s auch immer noch aber es ist so das
das die Propornfeminis sich einfach auch gesagt haben, also erstens haben wir sexuelles Verlangen ganz genauso wie
die Männer und es es geht nicht an das unser sexuelles Verlangen unsichtbar ist. Pornographie war schon immer aus Sicht der Männer
es war es war immer in irgendeiner Form aus der männlichen Perspektive und das geht nicht, wir brauchen jetzt also wir möchten
auch gerne das unser sexuelles Verlangen nicht mehr unsichtbar ist sondern das möchten wir genauso dargestellt wissen und wir
möchten wir möchten das auch öffentlich postulieren das wir das überhaupt haben. Ja und also das das zum einen und zum anderen
natürlich möchte man auch die Deutungshoheit über was ist denn Sexualität, was ist denn Pornographie das möchte man nicht allein
den Männer überlassen. Das finde ich auch ganz vernünftig weil wir stellen ja nun mal irgendwie die Hälfte der Gesellschaft und
warum nicht auch vertre... also raus aus dieser aus dieser unsichtbaren Schmuddel Ecke und das ist halt das ist ne gute Sache ja.
Also weibliche Sexualität ist eine Sache die, warum sollte man die nicht in irgendeiner Form auch zelebrieren und darstellen
und warum sollten sich nicht Frauen irgendwie auf Pornos einen runterholen dürfen, können und so und das geht halt mit Pornos aus
männlicher Perspektive, das ist halt das was wir gewohnt sind zu sehen ja. Aber warum nicht auch mal Pornos machen in
in der Frauen ihre... oder in der Frauen das Gefühl haben jetzt wird ihre Perspektive auch mal war genommen.
Was macht diese Perspektive aus? Ich meine zunächst einmal Sex ist ja son brauchst so zu sagen beide ja also reden jetzt immer vom
heterosexuellen Sex. Kein Porno ohne Frau so zu sagen das heiß die Frauen sind zumindest schon mal dabei was was ist die Änderung
der Perspektive dies dann für Frauen interessanter macht?
Also es gibt ganz ganz viele verschiedene Ansetzte ne. Also es gibt zum Beispiel dir Girlfriendfilms die haben dann versucht
das ist auch noch außem außem letzten Jahrtausend. Aber die haben dann versucht zum Beispiel Pornofilme ohne Männer
zu machen also das geht’s tatsächlich nur um um weibliche Sexualität die Dargestellt wird aber Männer kommen nicht vor.
ehem
das ist auch alles sehr sehr weichgespült und alles so mit Weichzeichner und alles so, erst ist denn muss irgendwie
mit geworben werden umeinander und ganz und erst mal drüber reden und so und dann geht’s so langsam zur Sache.
Das war das war en Ansatz.
Mit Massagestab oder ohne?
Ohne ohne das also war alles ganz ganz liebevoll und so.
Ok
Und dann natürlich ist ja Sex immer auch son bisschen son ja also Pornographie wie gesagt da geht’s ja darum um um den Blick
und dieser Blick wurde einfach geändert also du hast in in der modernen Pornographie oder in der Pornographie des 20. Jahrhunderts
ist die Frau immer son bisschen passiv immer son bisschen unterwürfig ja so dieses "ja gib’s mir", "ja machs mir",
hmm
"ich will das und mach mit mir was du willst" so dieses passive
Ja
und wenn man es schafft diesen diesen passiven Status son bisschen auf zu heben zu kontaktarieren und die Frau halt tatsächlich
auch son bisschen als aktiv und "ich such mir das selber aus" und " ich möchte jetzt mal selber entscheiden was ich hier mache
und mit wem ich das mache und wie und legt dich jetzt mal da hin" und so dann hast du wieder son sone ganz anderes Selbstbewusstsein
und dann haste die die Deutungshoheit also auch son bisschen verändert. Du hast halt irgendwie für dich definiert das Sex oder
das Pornographie Frauen in Pornographie nicht nur der passive Teil sein müssen ja sondern sie können auch tatsächlich
nen anderen Teil und es spricht halt zu Leuten also es spricht halt mehr zu dem was die Leute in ihrer Realität kennen natürlich ne.
Und findet das statt, also ich meine ist das ne nennenswerte Bewegung?
Ja das ist zunehmend also es gibt es gibt mittlerweile die Feminispornawards, da werden jährlich in in Kanada
die besten feministischen Filme pornographischen pornographischen Filme auch gekürt.
ehem
und es gibt in Berlin das das Pornofilmfestivel wo tatsächlich quwier und feministischer Porn auch ausgezeichnet wird
und gezeigt wird und das hat also das verändert sich gerade. Gerade auch mit dem Internet. Es gibt halt jetzt immer mehr
Menschen die sagen "also dieser dieser hedero 0 8 15 Porno der spricht mich nicht an das ist nicht meine Welt, das möchte ich nicht sehen,
sondern ich möchte ..." und dieses "..." das erfährt jetzt durch diese Möglichkeit der Differenzierung erfährt das auch echt
eine ja eine (popular) ein ein Gewinn an Popularität und das ist jetzt auch mittlerweile hip und cool Pornos zu kucken.
Das finde ich gut.
Finds du so?
Ja natürlich... kannst du irgendwo hin gehen und sagen ich kuck Pornos und alle Leute finden dich blöd? Also oder oder sagen "Ihh
Porn ihh du kuckst ihh du kuckst Pornos ihh"
Naja man ist ja auch immer son bisschen in seiner Blase deswegen ist es schwierig da so eine allgemein gültige Aussage
drauf zu sagen... ich würde das so unterstreichen das das sich auf jeden Fall lockert. Also es ist nicht mehr so verspannt.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ändern also ich rede jetzt so zu sagen von meiner von meinem Eindruck wie die gesamte Gesellschaft
das sieht
hm
Weil ich meine wir haben ja immer noch dieses Tabu ding ja
Ja es kommt son bisschen drauf an also in der
Porno ist böse und grad in der Politik so ja oh Gott Internet ja die Kinder können jetzt ja könnten sogar auf Pornos stoßen
ja sollen sie sich doch lieber bitte den Tatort an schauen wo jeden Sonntag Leute erschossen werden.
Genau also ich ich würd mich auch nicht auf niederbayrische Dorf stellen und dann auf dem Marktplatz sagen ich kucke Pornos.
Also ich mein das wäre zu mindest ne Diskussion die dann länger ist aber es ist mittlerweile so das das Pornographie
sich soweit ausdifferenziert hat das halt Pornographie nicht mehr das Synonym ist für die Unterdrückung oder die sexuelle Unterdrückung
der Frau. Das ist mittlerweile kein Synonym mehr und das finde ich gut. Weil das natürlich auch bedeutet das
momentan gesellschaftliche Gruppen auch das rezipieren die das vorher nicht rezipiert haben weil das einfach nichts war
womit sie sich identifizieren konnten ja.
Ja... Was würdest du denn sagen wäre sone kontemporäre Definition von Pornographie? Was ist es denn heute, jetzt oder was beginnt es zu
sein, was ist Aufgabe und Sichtweise?
Es sind Darstellungen von ganz ganz abstrakt sexuellen Akten die auf den Zuschauer erregend wirken sollen.
Aber so abstrakt sind sie ja jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Naja es kommt drauf an in welche Fetischrichtung du gehst, also wie gesagt es gibt Porno es gibt es gibt Dinge, Darstellungen
die sind für bestimmte Leute sexuell erregend und deswegen pornographisch und du würdest davor stehen und sagen "he".
Hast du da mal ein Beispiel?
Ja zum Beispiel Gips Gipsbeinfetisch ja, es gibt Leute
Gipsbein?
Ja es gibt Leute die finden das sexuell erregend Frauen oder oder Menschen in Gips in Gipsbeinen und Gipsarmen zu sehen
und dann auch auf diese Gipsbeine diese Gipsbeine in sexuelle Handlungen zu verwickeln. Ich persönlich das ist nicht mein Fetisch
weiste und deswegen kann ich sagen "ok das erregt mich jetzt nicht, für mich ist das keine Pornographie sondern einfach nur...)
Ok ok ja
Es gibt ein eine relativ große Interessensgruppe die findet das di findet das sexuell erregend für die ist das natürlich Pornographie
im klassischen Sinne es erregt sie es sexuelle Darstellungen die sie erregen.
Ok aber es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so der Hit unter den Fetischen oder?
Naja aber Kuck mal also ein ganz ganz riesiger Fetisch "Fußfetisch" ja sexuelle Handlungen an und mit Füßen.
Es gibt es gibt eine ganz ganz große Gruppe die findet das sexuell erregend für die ist das Pornographie und ich kann mir
vorstellen also wenn ich jetzt nicht wüsste das das Pornographie sein soll, für mich identifiziert sich das nicht so auf den ersten Blick
weil das sind angezogene Frauen mit Füßen.
Ja
Ja das ist für mich jetzt nicht nicht auf den ersten Blick als Pornographie zu identifizieren weil ich diesen Fetisch nicht teile.
ehem
Ja aber jemand der diesen Fetisch tatsächlich hat oder der irgendwie auf diese Art und Weise seiner Sexualität irgendwie
ja der das irgendwie erregen findet für den ist das natürlich pornographisch.
Ok aber wenn ich mein, wenn ich jetzt Fetisch höre dann denk ich irgendwie als erstes Lack, Leder, Halsband
das ist für mich in meinem limitierten Hirn ist das son bisschen das Synonym dafür.
Nja da feh... also nee der Fetisch bedeutet ja eigentlich nur das du Dinge sexualisierst die jetzt nicht nicht unbedingt also
die nicht die primären Geschlechtsteile sind sondern du du sexualisierst halt Dinge oder Gegenstände oder gewisse Körperteile...
Ja auch das verhüllen ne ist ja auch son Teil aber eben auch so dieses fesseln, einsperren...
Ja da geht’s halt viel um
Marschier ich jetzt in die falsche Richtung oder?
Nö nö nö aber das das ist halt Sex als Macht ne Machtspiel was ja was ja Sexualität immer ist und natürlich ist das auch was
was sich unglaublich gut darstelle lässt also Machtspiele lassen sich ja visuell einfach sehr sehr gut filmisch darstellen.
Deswegen ist das auch was was sehr sehr häufig einfach kommt wenn du wenn du irgendwie Bilder oder Filme siehst
weil sich das so gut darstellt. Es gibt Fetische die lassen sich nicht so besonders gut darstellen oder haben halt sone kleine
Interessensgemeinde das das Internet für diese Interessensgemeinden halt ein großer Segen ist weil sie dann tatsächlich
Gleichgesinnte finden. Na es gibt halt Fetische die sich mir jetzt nicht erschließen und aber um Gottes Willen also wenn wenn
Leute das irgendwie einverständlich miteinander machen dann
Passt schon!
Passt das schon ja aber ich muss jetzt nicht nackt irgendwie durch den Wald rennen mit irgendwie jemanden auf meinen Schultern
und also so weiste das sind einfach so Dinge wo ich mir sage (jeje) muss ich jetzt persö... aber wie gesagt bitte
Ok
Und das Internet ist total hilfreich weil sich solche Leute dann zusammen finden können und...
Ok ist im Prinzip wieder der Sieg der Nische also es gibt so zu sagen für jeden Fetisch gibt irgendwie das passende Angebot
und Leute finden das und sind sich dann so zu sagen ihrer Vorlieben bewusster und entspannter das sie irgendwie nicht alleine auf
diesen Planeten sind.
Ja genau.
Und du findest auch generell das Argument das Pornos jetzt für Kinder schädlich sind was ja so zu sagen son politmem ist
dem würdest du so nicht..
Also ich würde jetzt sagen
das würdest du nicht unterschreiben
alles ab der Pubertät also ich finde das Pornographie in der Tat also son bisschen der Teil der der Oberschul
also der Sexualkundeunterricht sein sollte. Weil man darf drüber nicht reden weil sie sind ab 18, Sexualkundeunterricht
ist so irgendwie mit 16 glaub ich 8. Klasse 15 16 sind die dann. Das heißt du darfst den das natürlich nicht zeigen aber du darfst
die reden, es wird auch nicht drüber gesprochen und das heißt das was eigentlich alle Politiker als Problem ansehen ist dieses
die Kids kucken Pornos und denken dann das ist das ist das wies im Schlafzimmer laufen sollte.
Ja
Das das so nicht läuft das merken die von alleine ja aber das sind halt so Dinge, würde man drüber reden und würde man auch zeigen
Kuck mal das sieht immer gleich aus hast du dich schon mal gefragt wieso. Das wäre total hilfreich ja wenn das nicht so totgeschwiegen wäre.
Deswegen bin ich schon also der Meinung das man das in irgendeiner Form thematisieren sollte im Oberschulunterricht ja.
Weil es findet ja statt ich meine es kann mir keiner erklären
Auf welcher Art und Weise meinst du könnte man das thematisieren?
Im Sexualunterricht also...
Was Porno zeigen
Porno zeigen und dann sagen Kuck mal so und so und so haste gesehen die machen das nur so weil da die Kamera ist und die kuckt nur
deswegen in die Kamera damit das in irgendeiner Form was mit dir zu tun hat, damit du dich irgendwie erregt fühlst. Ja und unzwar
unzwar du als heterosexueller Mann das diese Pornos diese heterosexuellen Pornos sind natürlich total normiert sind und auch nur
auf eine bestimmte Klientel abzielen. Das ist was wenn du das mal erklärst dann siehst du das auch und dann differenzierst du
auch zwischen was mach ich zu Hause in meinem Schlafzimmer und was ist das und das das einfach nicht die Norm ist sondern
das das ich immer die Norm bin also es gibt keine Norm deswegen ist das was ich tue immer ok so.
Und das das sind Sachen dass das kann man das kann man Jugendlichen beibringen und ich glaub da kann man echt ne ganze Menge
hm
Herzensleid auch verhindern, wenn man halt sagt diese Normierung die du in Pornographie erlebst in heterosexueller
Pornographie oder auf Youporn die gibt es gar nicht in Wirklichkeit ja des heißt also wenn du diesen Gipsbeinfetisch hast
um Gottes Willen such dir Leute die das auch cool finden und mach es es ist ok.
Ja
Sagt doch keiner was dagegen so lange du Leute findest die das cool finden und die sagen ich gebe mein explizites Einverständnis do it!
Was würdest du meine wie groß so der Anteil von Pornokultur ist jetzt bei der Erzeugung von Rollenbilder in der Gesellschaft
die wir ja durch alles haben Werbung, Umgang, Regeln ,Vorschriften...
Naja es spiegelt natürlich ne Menge und wie gesagt wir haben ja je wir haben halt die Momentan also dieser diese
Momentane Porno also das Bilder der Frau zum Beispiel im Pornofilm ist ja extrem unterwürfig ja also das ist ich
rede jetzt von von heterosexueller Massenproduzierter Pornographie
Ja
Das ist immer noch sehr unterwürfig und das natürlich auch son bisschen dann Ergebnis davon das das Tabu ist also wir habe eine
eine Gesellschaft in der Frauen immer emanzipierter werden noch nicht natürlich wir haben immer noch Bedürfnisse für mehr
Gleichstellung das ist noch nicht passiert aber es ist so das diese Unterwürfigkeit nicht mehr der Statusquo ist wie in der
viktorianischen Gesellschaft wo es noch hieß du ehrst bitte deinen Mann und wenn der Sex will dann hast du da bitte schön irgendwie zu liegen.
Ja
Und das das muss mittlerweile nicht mehr sein sondern man hat auch sone gewisse Emanzipation in im in der persönlichen Sexualität
und deswegen ist das neue Tabu halt diese Unterwürfigkeit. Naja und deswegen hat man dieses das ist son bisschen dieser
dieser Stausquo aber das ändert sich halt gerade weil es eben Pornographie auch mittlerweile gibt die einfach sagt das das das ist natürlich
das ist Blödsinn ja das ist nicht unsere Erfahrungswelt und das ist auch nicht schön das wollen wir nicht sehen und deswegen mach wir Pornos
mit starken Frauen oder machen halt Pornos die auch andere Körper einfach auch mal zeigen ja immer so diese
riesige Brüste bei Frauen, riesige Schwänze bei Männern
Ja
Also das das sind einfach so Normen die wollen wir nicht mehr haben sondern wir möchten einfach unterschiedliche Körper sehen
so wir wollen auch mal große, kleine, dicke, dünne Körper die sich irgendwie verändern solche Dinge also das ist ne wir wollen einfach
mal andere Dinge sehen
Ja mal normale Dinge sehen vielleicht auch?
Ja einfach alles was Normal ist ja immer son schwieriger Begriff und Normal ist ja son Kampfbegriff
Also sagen... Ja ok Normal ist scheiß Wort Dinge die häufiger vorkommen
Dinge die einfach unserer sehr ausdifferenzierten Lebenswelt entsprechen
Ja
Ja da komm zum Beispiel Transgenderkörper vor, da kommen quwierekörper vor die einfach wo man einfach sagt
wir wir wollen uns jetzt nicht einordnen lassen da kommen halt kleine, große, dicke, dünne verschiedene Konstellationen
ja nicht immer nur irgendwie er auf sie in der Missionar Stellung und dann abspritzen und so also das ne sondern einfach ne
differenziertere Darstellung von Sexualität und da nähert sich die Pornographie dann halt auch der Sexualität wieder an.
Also es ist halt so dass die das Pornos wie gesagt mit mit dem eigentlich mit der eigentlichen Sexualität nicht viel zu tun haben
das weiß man spätestens wenn man nen Money shot sieht also wenn einfach sieht das Männer auf das Gesicht der Frau
abspritzen was ja nicht so naja wie soll ich sagen also im Porno ist das immer so das ist halt irgendwie der Money shot das Ende
dieser Sequenz dann
Money shot heißt das
Money shot heist das ja camshot, Money shot
Ja ich hatte es halt unter camshot aufen...
Genau also in der in der wissenschaftlichen Literatur ist das der Money shot.
Warum denn Money?
Weil Porno(äh)Darsteller damals nur bezahlt wurden wenn sie das liefern konnten.
Ahhh versteh
Genau also das ist der Money Short und ja das das sich nicht so eins zu eins auf das Schlafzimmer übersetzen lässt ist ja eigentlich klar
und das das für unsere für unser Auge wichtig ist ja das der Mann da perfamt das ist für unsere Rezeptionskultur die wir bei Pornographie
halt haben ganz relevant ja. Kein Porno ohne Money shot.
(hm)
Und das sind halt so Konventionen wie jetzt mit mit dieser ausdifferenzierten Pornographie tatsächlich auch überworfen werden
und das finde ich wunderschön also
(hm)
Das nähert sich jetzt so langsam einer Sexualität an. Was ich ganz interessant finde.
Das Internet bringt ja jetzt einige Änderungen rein nicht nur was so die Verfügbarkeit von Filmen betrifft so also ne wie das ja
die ganze Filmindustrie betrifft also es ist nicht nur so das Porno überall ist und auch nicht nur das sagen wir auch jetzt
glaub ich die Filmkultur sich ändert weg von hin weg von diesen langen Filmen hin zu kurzen Clips und dann eben auch
extrem privaten Clips Amateursachen bei Youporn und anderen Portalen ist ja alles irgendwie direkt verfügbar und hier klick hier
komm jetzt. Was ich ja auch noch sehe ist das die Internettechnologie ja auch ne ganz andere Dienstleistungskultur dort bedient
also das vornehmlich wahrscheinlich Frauen ich weiß nicht von Männern kenn das jetzt nicht aber ich würd das jetzt mal nicht ausschließen
kenn mich da in dem Schwulenbereich auch jetzt gar nicht aus aber was so typisch ist so, einzelne Frau hat ihre eigene Webseite
hat so zu sagen ihren eigenen Brand und verkauft sich quasi so verkauft so den Direktzugang ne gibt Teasarvideos und Bildchen
und man zahlt halt irgendwie regelmäßig und dann gib’s irgendwie die Webcam irgendwie zur regelmäßigen Zeitpunkten. Ist ja dann auch
etwas was so zu sagen bis vor kurzem technologisch überhaupt nicht denkbar war
Naja das war das ist ja so späte 90er Jahrtausendwände son bisschen diese camgirlkultur. Ja na klar also das Internet
bietet natürlich diese scheinbar direkten Zugang was man natürlich auch sagen muss dieser das ist da ist ja auch viel einfach Geschichte
und Fabrikation also dieses Branding das man denkt immer hat so den unmittelbaren Zugang zu jemanden aber das ist natürlich auch
Passade oder oder die gehen ja auch nach Hause und haben dann irgendwie ein anderes Leben ne also.
Ja
Ja aber da verschwimmt also gerade bei den Camgirls verschwimmt auch son bisschen wieder dieses die der Bereich zwischen
Prostitution und und Pornographie.
Ne und da hat man wieder son bisschen das ist bisschen Retro frühen Stummfilm hatten wir, Prostituierte die sich so zu sagen
Ja
dann auch als Pornodarstellerinnin Casten haben lassen weil das die einzigen Frauen waren die dafür zur Verfügung standen
und bei den Camgirls verschwimmt das ja auch wieder weil natürlich sehr direkt auch darauf eingehen was die Kunden dann
die jetzt da verbunden sind mit den was die wollen.
Du meinst jetzt wenn es so one-in-one...
Ja wenn die oder die könne denn so chatten und dann
Ja ok
So ja.. und dad... durch diesen Livemoment verschwimmt das son bisschen und diese dieses dieses Amateurgenre was du da vorhin
erwähnt hast das ist ja auch so das beziffert ja eigentlich nur Körper die ein bisschen differenziert also so son bisschen ausdifferenzierter
Körpernormen also das da halt nicht... Amateur heißt ja eigentlich auch nur irgendwie Frauen ohne Silikon ja. Oder oder Männer die
halt jetzt nicht irgendwie den mega Schwanz haben.
Jor oder halt so wirklich richtig private
Ja das lassen sie dich glauben aber du glaubst doch nicht das ist ne das ist ne richtige Industrie. Das sind natürlich Leute die gecastet
werden und so bald da ne Kamera ist hast du ja keine natürliche sexuelle Situation mehr sondern da hast du ne Kamera, dann hast du da
den Mann mit dem Ton, du hast dann den Resesuer der sagt "du wir sehen jetzt gerade Garnichts mach doch mal dein Bein hoch"
und das ist ja keine authentische Situation mehr sondern es ist eine Situation die für die Kamera hergestellt wird und die auch diesen
Normen der Kamera und dieses diesen Code der der Rezeption wieder folgt das heißt du musst das in irgendeiner Form so machen das
die Kamera was sieht ja. Also du kannst halt nicht einfach nur drauf halten da siehst du ja überhau... ich mein wenn Leu...
wenn zwei Leute Sex haben, siehst du ja nicht so viel wenn du da einfach nur daneben stehst. Das heißt du musst das schon so machen
mit halt doch mal dein Bein so hoch damit ich mit der Kamera darunter komm.
Ja
Ja also das ist doch das ist ja keine Situ...aber ich meine ich weiß ich kenn privat leb....
Ja ist ist Heisenberg wieder ne so die Beobachtung ver verfälscht so zu sagen das Betrachtete.
Genau und das also und und das ist natürlich so dass diese Leute dann nicht so Karriere machen sondern es gibt halt diese Starsysteme
und dieses Amateursystem aber das sind natürlich Leute die das semi Professionell machen ja und es gibt auf Youporn ja auch dieses
hier sind es echte Amateure und so aber wenn man sich das mal genauer ankuckt sind das natürlich zu einem sehr sehr großen Prozentsatz
auch ausschließlich aus Kommerziell vertriebenen Filmen.
Ja
Das sind nicht Leute die einfach nur exizubinistisch veranlagt sind das gibt es dort bestimmt auch aber das ist denk ich mal nicht der Großteil
und das ist das was wir glauben wollen oder das was natürlich auch der clam ist aber das ist ja ein clam auch einer gesamten Industrie,
nämlich dieser Amateurindustrie also das darf man nicht vergessen das das auch tatsächlich nen ganzes Genre ist ja.
Und das das vermarktet wird so.
Ja naja gut aber ist halt auch Porno.
Jor klar.
Kommt mit dazu und ist definitiv son neues Phänomen und weckt ja dann wahrscheinlich in gewisser Hinsicht aber auch schon diesen
Wunsch nach Authentizität ab also auch wenn’s nicht authentisch ist ist es zumindest ne Produktion die ja im Prinzip genau das was du vorhin
auch so gefordert hast so das irgendwie eben nicht immer die dicken Titten und Monsterschwänze sind sondern halt auch was dazwischen.
Nja das Ding ist ja ja aber bei Youporn ist natürlich das schöne du hast ne Suchmaschine und du kannst halt nach spezifischen Dingen
suchen das heißt also wenn du auf dicke Titten stehst dann kann gibst du halt dicke Titten ein
Ja
bzw. das englisch äquivalent und dann findest du was du haben willst ja und das kann das ist natürlich schön aber das darf
man nicht vergessen ist auch wieder alles auf dem männlichen Blick gemünzt ne. Das da einfach auch ganz ganz viel
Content drin ist der wieder mit dieser männlichen Perspektive, Amateurpornos zum Beispiel funktionieren ganz häufig so das der
Kameramann Teil der Szenerie ist und dieser ganz klassische Kamerawinkel von Oben rauf auf den eigenen Schwanz
der gerade iner Frau steckt
Ja im Prinzip so first poison...
Genau das das ist das heißt PoV Point of View
Jaja
und Point-of-View-Porn ist halt tatsächlich das ist der ultimative männlich Blick ja. Das ist so ich kucke auf mein eingen...
Das ist eigentlich Point of male view so zu sagen
Ja genau Point of male view und und das ist auch was was im Amateurbereich sehr sehr stark ein ein visuelles Muster
was sich den gesamten Amateurbereich zieht und das ist natürlich was wenn ich jetzt als heterosexuelle Frau... ja ich mein klar
irgendwo aber so richtig meine Perspektive ist das halt nicht ne.
Vielleicht gib’s auch den Point of female view also gibt’s auch irgendwie vergleichbares?
Nicht in dem in dem großen Maßen gibt es aber das sind dann halt Projekte was es halt gibt ist irgendwie der Versuch einer gerechten
einer einer einer Geschlechtergerechten Pornographie die halt auf dieses male Point verzichtet und die die Frau halt tatsächlich
in heterosexueller Pornographie nicht nur als williges was auch immer Luda darstellt sondern irgendwie so von wegen ich hab hier auch
ein eigenen Willen hallo....
Ja aber ich meine ist das kein Markt?
Das ist ein zunehmender Markt natürlich also gerade gerade Leute d(äh äh) die sich nicht vertreten fühlen in der in der momentanen
heterosexuellen Pornographie die sagen halt machen wir halt unseren eigenen scheiß und das machen sie und das wird gekauft und das
ist ein wachsender Markt natürlich also merkt man auch.
Also wenn man so zu sagen heute in die Pornographie einsteigen wollen würde wäre das ein Wachstumsmarkt?
Es naja klar vor allen Dingen wenn du als Mensch der sagt also das was ich hier so mache das ist momentan in der Por also das
was mich an macht und geil macht das ist noch nicht vertreten ja klar also das ist ist ein ist ein wachsender ein wachsender Sektor
und ich find das auch schön das das halt Menschen sagen wir haben halt nicht normierte Körper, wir haben nicht normierte
Beziehungen und sexuelles Verlangen und das möchten wir auch in irgendeiner Form dargestellt wissen ja.
(hm)
Weil natürlich dieser dieser dieser männlich dominierte Blick Porno ist halt nicht mehr nur für Männer ja, es gibt auch
genügend Frauen die sagen also ich möcht jetzt mal ordentlich ne geile Geschichte haben und wo kann ich das hier, wo gibt’s denn das hier...
Wo geht’s denn hin mit dem Porno haste da irgendwie nen Eindruck so siehst du zum Beispiel ne Chance das das das dieses
diese Tabuisierung mal ein Ende findet oder ist das so ein Evergreen?
Hahh es ist halt son hahh es ist halt son inhärenter Teil also dieses ich mache was was ich so zu sagen also so dieses
ha es ist schon aufregend was zu tun was jetzt nicht gesellschaftlich so anerkannt ist natürlich ne.
Ja ist es vielleicht gut für die Gesellschaft das das pornographische Tabuisiert ist?
Naja es kommt son bisschen darauf an wie man das sieht. Also natürlich gibt’s diesen diesen Moment der Karses das man sagt man
kuckt jetzt diesen Porno und jetzt irgendwie dann dadurch ja gereinigt in irgendeiner Form. Da glaube ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht so dran aber ich glaube schon das wenn man darüber reden also ich mein wenn ich über über mein über mein Sexleben reden müsste
oder oder wenn das irgendwie son Kaffeekränziengesprächsthema wäre dann wär das nicht so spannend also wäre es anders spannend.
Und ich finde son bisschen dieses dieser Kitzel der darf schon da sein und dieses das aufregende und dieses hach jetzt kuck ich mal
was und jetzt mach ich mal was und das ist klar das ist son das ist son inherenter Teil. Das ist aber auch ein Teil davon
unserer Geschichte also wir haben Pornographie immer als irgendwo was wenn nicht gesetzlich dann moralisch verbotenes
oder son bisschen außerhalb der Gesellschaft stehendes empfunden und das ist... das ändert sich das ändert sich in den Maße
wie unsere Sexualität tatsächlich wie wir über Sexualität reden können wie wir auch über Pornographie reden können #
und das findet ja der dieser Diskurs findet ja zunehmend statt. Also es gibt ja also ich hab das ganz krass gemerkt ich war auf dem
ich glaub auf dem vorletzten Pornofilmfestival und dann kam meine Mutter und meinte nimm mich mal mit. Ich will einfach mal kucken
was da so los ist und meine Mutter ist Mitte 60 und die war dann da und hat sich irgendwie auch was angekuckt und..
Wo war das Pornofilmfestival?
Das ist in Berlin jedes Jahr im Herbst das kann ich sehr Empfehlen da werden halt vor allen Dingen auch Pornos gezeigt die eben
son bisschen von diesem also die einfach mit diesem 0 8 15 hedero Garnichts mehr zu tun haben sondern das ist quirfeministischer
Porno das sind das sind Porno die teilweise in die Kunstrichtung gehen das ist ne wundervolle Atmosphäre, es ist ne sehr sehr
sexpositive, pornpositive Atmosphäre und da komm Porno also Pornoregisseure und Regisseurinnen aus aller Welt.
Ja
Die sich dort so zu sagen über die neusten Entwicklungen unterhalten und das ist es ist eine wahrsinnig tolle Erfahrung also
das ist tatsächlich in Deutschland das Festival um mal zu kucken wo es hin geht mit der Pornographie Entwicklung
(ehem)
Und ja sehr Empfehlenswert auch ne wundervolle Atmosphäre so.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen ich meine in dieser Pornobranche die sind ja auch irgendwie in einer gewissen Art und Weise auch immer
unglaublich entspannt. Ich mein wenn du einmal weißt das du dich in der Tabuzone der Gesellschaft bewegst dann haste halt
schnell so diesen Effekt mit lebt sich völlig ungeniert ja.
Jaa es kommt aber auch echt drauf an in welcher in welcher Branche du da noch bist oder welches Genre du bedienst. Also es gibt ja
es gibt ja Pornos, wenn man in Amerika zum Beispiel ist und sagt Germanporn dann haben die sofort ne Vorstellung
und zwar haben sie ne ganz ganz konkrete Vorstellung, kennst du GGG German-Gu-Girls? German-Gu-Girls ist der Exportschlager
schlecht hin das ist eine Münchner Firma. German-Gu-Girls hatte leider ist sie mittlerweile so zu sagen in Pornorente
sie hatten Betti. Betti ist der Star gewesen von GGG und Betti gurgelt Sperma also das ist German-Gu-Girls ist sehr Bukkakelastig
also Bukkake ist ganz ganz viel Männer mit Sperma und sehr viel Schleim und Körperflüssigkeiten das ist so sehr
Körperflüssigkeiten zentriert
Ja
dieses Genre. Und German-Gu-Girls ist der Exportschlager in Amerika das heißt also wenn wenn man so 0 8 15 Amerikaner die mal
von Germanporn gehört haben das ist so das was sie kennen und das ist würde ich sagen jetzt nicht unbedingt also da hört man
jetzt nicht unbedingt wie sehr sie da willko.. also so ja sexpositve und irgendwie sagen Frauenpower und so weil das auch nicht
die Art die Art und Weise ist wie dort gearbeitet wird das ist sehr männerlasstig die Produktion. Frauen werden kommen da meistens
nur auf das Drehgelände wenn sie nackt sind.
Ja
und das ist tatsächlich immer noch sehr makadominiert.
Ok verstehe.
Aber das liegt auch an dieser Art und Weise dieser Pornographie also das ist eine sehr harte brutale und und nicht sehr Frauen also
nicht nicht sehr frauenfreundlich also ich find das nicht also für mich als Frau bietet sich da nicht so viel.
Verstehe (...) aber grundsätzlich siehst du das eher positiv? Also da entwickelt sich gibt’s auch ne also missinterpretiert ich das jetzt gerade
also...
Nö natürlich ist das super
Also es tut sich was?
Ja
Und wo sollte es hingehen was was wär so zu sagen dein Wunsch?
Naja mein Wunsch ist das das einfach alle Leute das oder oder das das Erwachsene Menschen tatsächlich das Gefühl
haben das sie in irgendeiner Form auch repräsentiert sind und das also das sie nicht mehr vorherrscht so ich bin abnormal in meiner
Sexualität weil ich einfach ne... also das gibt halt es gibt Dinge die werden die werden von unserer Gesellschaft verboten die sind auch
tatsächlich rechtlich verboten das sind vor allen Dingen Kinder, Tiere, Tote aber wenn ich ein ein wenn meine Sexualität
Erwachsene Menschen inkludiert die ihr Einverständnis zu dieser Praxis gegeben haben dann sollte das irgendwie nicht als pervers
oder abnormal oder so in irgendeiner Form gebrandmarkt werden ja.
(hm)
Und das finde ich das diese diese momentane Entwicklung hin zu einer differenzierten Pornographie finde ich ja eigentlich ganz schön
weil sich da jeder wieder finden kann.
Porno für alle!!!
Tina ich glaube wir haben's.
Ich glaub auch.
ne
ja
Vielen Dank das war’s hier bei CRE und geht bald wieder weiter mit neuen spaßigen Themen...bis bald.